Hello everyone and before today's show, I have incredibly exciting news for you about a live show. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be at the South Bank to do something that we have not done before. So you will be the first people to hear it. We are telling the story of what is the ultimate Victorian adventure. The date is 1868, the location is Abyssinia, and the Emperor of Abyssinia has been writing letters to Queen Victoria, who rather rudely has not replied to them. So the Emperor of Abyssinia, annoyed about this, has kidnapped a number of British subjects. In response, Britain sends an expedition to rescue the captives. and it is no exaggeration to say, it is massive. On this expedition, 13,000 soldiers, 40,000 animals,
大家好，在今天的节目开始之前，我有一个关于现场演出的重磅好消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将前往南岸艺术中心，去做一件我们从未做过的事情。所以你们将是第一批听到这个消息的人。我们将讲述一个终极维多利亚时代的冒险故事。时间是1868年，地点是阿比西尼亚，阿比西尼亚皇帝一直在给维多利亚女王写信，而女王却非常无礼地没有回复。于是，阿比西尼亚皇帝对此感到恼火，绑架了多名英国臣民。作为回应，英国派遣了一支远征军去营救人质。毫不夸张地说，这支队伍规模庞大。在这支远征军中，有13000名士兵，40000头牲畜，
including 44 elephants, and the British even put down a railway line to transport everything. It's an incredible story full of jaw-dropping events, ludicrous characters, lots of moustaches, lots of general Victorian shenanigans. And as I say, it is the first. time that we have ever done it on The Rest is History. I don't want to blow our trumpet, but I think it's going to be an absolute Rest Is History classic. So if you want to get a ticket for the ultimate Victorian adventure at the South Bank in London on Friday the 4th of September, you know where to go. The Rest is History.com. of the chines of apostasy in this land.
其中包括44头大象，英国人甚至铺设了一条铁路线来运输所有物资。这是一个令人难以置信的故事，充满了令人瞠目结舌的事件、荒谬的人物、大量的胡子，以及各种典型的维多利亚时代的闹剧。正如我所说，这是我们第一次在《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）节目中这样做。我不想自吹自擂，但我认为这绝对会成为《历史的余味》的经典之作。所以，如果你想在9月4日星期五在伦敦南岸艺术中心获得一张终极维多利亚时代冒险演出的门票，你知道该去哪里。The Rest is History.com。这片土地上背教的叮当声。
Open the eyes of thy people. Open the eyes of the Protestants of Alstair. Help them to say that through hegemonism, their heritage is being bartered. Their liberties are being sold. And Lord, may they shake the dust from off their feet. and come out and join with us in this battle, that we may stand together in the name of the Lord of hosts.
睁开你子民的眼睛。睁开阿尔斯特新教徒的眼睛。帮助他们说出，由于霸权主义，他们的遗产正在被交易。他们的自由正在被出卖。主啊，愿他们抖掉脚上的尘土，走出来加入我们的战斗，让我们以万军之主的名义站在一起。
We thank thee that thou didst bless the reformers, as they fought this battle in the 16th century, as thou blessed the covenanters, as they re-fought this battle in the era of the Puridans. And thou will bless us in the 20th century, for God is still the same. And he has not changed, nor ever will. And his truth shall reveal, and his word is quick and powerful, and sharper than any two-edged sword.
我们感谢你，因为你祝福了宗教改革者，正如他们在16世纪进行这场战斗一样；正如你祝福了盟约派，正如他们在清教徒时代重新进行这场战斗一样。你也会在20世纪祝福我们，因为上帝依然如故。他没有改变，也永远不会改变。他的真理必将显明，他的话语是活泼的、有功效的，比一切两刃的剑更快。
and these Irish Presbyterian ministers and Methodist clergymen and Church of Ireland rectors, if they need to be rectified, they would all take us back to Rome. Well, we're not going. We're not going. You can go if you want, but we will not go. So to anyone under the age of 40, that will sound as though I have been having a stroke. But to anyone who grew up in the 1970s and 1980s, that I hope will be a very familiar sound because it is the Reverend Ian Paisley, and he was giving a sermon there entitled called Why I am a Protestant on the 1st of March 1965.
如果这些爱尔兰长老会牧师、卫理公会神职人员和爱尔兰教会的教区牧师需要被纠正，他们会把我们所有人带回罗马。好吧，我们不去。我们不去。如果你想去，你可以去，但我们不会去。所以对于任何40岁以下的人来说，这听起来就像我中风了一样。但对于任何在20世纪70年代和80年代长大的人来说，我希望这听起来会非常熟悉，因为这是伊恩·佩斯利牧师，他在1965年3月1日发表了一篇题为《我为什么是新教徒》的布道。
And Dominant, he was the voice of hardline Protestant Ulster fundamentalism, wasn't he? He was the sworn foe of that whore of Babylon, the Church of Rome, and the champion of the Ulster loyalist cause. And the thing that's sensational about Ian Paisley is that, I mean, he really does sound like he is ringing all the Reformation greatest hits. He sounds like he stepped out from the pages of a 16th or 17th century anti-papist tract. But the amazing thing about that, I mean, he made it in the year that help was released when London was starting to swing when the mini skirts were coming out.
多米尼克，他是强硬派阿尔斯特新教原教旨主义的代言人，不是吗？他是那个“巴比伦淫妇”——罗马教会的死敌，也是阿尔斯特保皇派事业的捍卫者。关于伊恩·佩斯利，最令人震惊的是，我的意思是，他听起来确实像是在演奏宗教改革时期所有的“热门金曲”。他听起来就像是从16或17世纪反教皇的小册子里走出来的一样。但令人惊奇的是，我的意思是，他是在《Help!》发行的那一年发表的演讲，当时伦敦开始变得时髦，迷你裙开始流行。
NASA's preparing to send a mission to the moon. The 60s are turning very, very groovy. But I mean, Ian Paisley, he's not groovy, is he? Whatever else you say about him, he's not groovy. No, and I don't think he would wish to be called groovy, Tom. I have to say that was a tremendous. That was a tremendous first of Ian Paisley. So you were riddled with uncharacteristic self-doubt before that recording.
美国国家航空航天局正准备执行登月任务。60年代变得非常、非常时髦。但我的意思是，伊恩·佩斯利，他一点也不时髦，对吧？无论你怎么评价他，他都不时髦。不，而且我认为他也不会希望被称为时髦，汤姆。我必须说，那是一段非常棒的伊恩·佩斯利的模仿。所以你在录音前充满了不寻常的自我怀疑。
I've been practicing quite a lot this morning. I think fair-minded observers would agree that was a tremendous performance. I woke up my friend Loss with the stentorian tones of my. My rhetoric. Lying a bed like a slattern. That's what I told her. Well, we'll come back to him pace later in this episode. I mean, he is an extraordinary character.
我今天早上练习了很多。我认为公正的观察者会同意那是一次精彩的表演。我用我那洪亮的声音吵醒了我的朋友洛斯。我的修辞。像个懒妇一样躺在床上。我就是这么告诉她的。好吧，我们稍后会在本集中回到佩斯利的话题。我的意思是，他是一个非凡的人物。
I mean, it's amazing to think that he ended up as first minister of Northern Ireland in coalition with Sinn Faye, by the way. Yeah, and they were Martin McGuinness, wasn't it? They were the chuckle brothers because they just spent the whole time chortling with each other. That's a twist. A twist that actually nobody could possibly have expected. Anyway, for four decades or so, his was one of the sort of identifiable trademark voices of a conflict that claimed thousands of lives, including the lives of almost 2,000 entirely innocent civilians, British and Irish. And today we call this conflict the Troubles, which is a very euthamistic way to talk about one of the darkest episodes in modern British and indeed Irish history.
我的意思是，想到他最终在北爱尔兰担任首席部长，并且与新芬党结盟，这真是太神奇了。是的，那是马丁·麦吉尼斯，对吧？他们是“咯咯笑兄弟”，因为他们整天都在互相傻笑。这真是一个转折。一个实际上没人能预料到的转折。总之，在大约四十年的时间里，他的声音是那场夺去数千人生命（包括近2000名完全无辜的平民，无论是英国人还是爱尔兰人）的冲突中，最具辨识度的标志性声音之一。今天，我们将这场冲突称为“动乱”（the Troubles），这是一种非常委婉的说法，用来描述现代英国乃至爱尔兰历史上最黑暗的篇章之一。
To give people a massive overview, it began with sectarian. in rioting in the streets of Northern Ireland, but it escalated into something much more sinister. Effectively a low-level civil war between rival paramilature groups and the British Army, and indeed murderous bombing campaigns, both in Ireland and in Britain. And at the peak of the violence in the early 1970s, which has a period we're talking a lot about in this series, almost 500 people were being killed every year, and a bomb was going off in Belfast every single day. And the victims of the troubles included not just British MPs, but as viewers of the Crown will know, the Queen's second cousin, Lord Mountbatten, the last viceroy of India who was killed by a bomb in 1979. And of course, it also killed shop assistants and barmen and singers and hairdressers and housewives and schoolchildren who were shot and blown up because they had the wrong name or they belonged to the wrong church or because they just had.
给人们一个宏观的概述，它始于北爱尔兰街头的宗派骚乱，但随后升级为更险恶的事情。实际上，这是敌对准军事组织与英国军队之间的一场低烈度内战，而且在爱尔兰和英国都发生了致命的爆炸袭击。在20世纪70年代初暴力活动的顶峰时期——这也是我们在本系列中讨论很多的时期——每年有近500人丧生，贝尔法斯特每天都会发生爆炸。动乱的受害者不仅包括英国议员，正如《王冠》的观众所知，还有女王的表亲蒙巴顿勋爵，这位最后一任印度总督在1979年被炸弹炸死。当然，它也夺去了店员、酒保、歌手、理发师、家庭主妇和学童的生命，他们仅仅因为名字不对、属于错误的教会，或者仅仅因为他们
happened to be in the wrong place at the wrong time. So this series is going to look at the first years of the troubles, how they came and how they reached their peak at the end of 1972. And of course, it is a very contentious subject. I mean, lots of listeners, whether they're British or Irish or indeed from elsewhere, they may have very strong views and they may remember or have people who are involved in the conflict. And Tom, obviously, we should say right to the beginning, we are obviously British and we live through it. So it's not like we don't have preconceptions. But there are an awful lot of books now about this written by, you know, very fair-minded, balanced historians, both British and Irish and indeed people from Northern Ireland.
碰巧在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。所以这个系列将审视动乱的最初几年，它们是如何开始的，以及它们是如何在1972年底达到顶峰的。当然，这是一个非常有争议的话题。我的意思是，很多听众，无论是英国人、爱尔兰人还是来自其他地方的人，他们可能有非常强烈的观点，他们可能记得或者有亲人参与了这场冲突。汤姆，显然我们应该在一开始就说，我们显然是英国人，而且我们亲身经历了那个时期。所以并不是说我们没有先入为主的观念。但现在有大量关于此的书籍，是由非常公正、平衡的历史学家撰写的，包括英国人、爱尔兰人，甚至是北爱尔兰人。
And I think it is actually perfectly possible to try to give a balanced, fairly balanced account and that's what we're going to try and do. I think, I mean, I think that is true. I think a certain degree of distance has enabled studies of the troubles. Yeah. I mean, so there was that brilliant series on BBC, once upon a time in Northern Ireland that I just thought was impeccably balanced and unfair. And I know that you are an impeccably balanced and fair man. Oh, that's kind.
而且我认为，尝试给出一个平衡的、相当平衡的叙述实际上是完全可能的，这正是我们将要尝试做的。我想，我的意思是，我认为这是真的。我认为一定程度的距离感使得对动乱的研究成为可能。是的。我的意思是，BBC那个精彩的系列片《北爱尔兰往事》（Once Upon a Time in Northern Ireland），我当时就觉得它非常平衡且公正。而且我知道你是一个非常平衡和公正的人。哦，你太客气了。
So I look forward to you emulating that. Wow, no pressure them. So actually, even where you start the story is a political choice in itself. Right, because the coming of the Normans. Right, you could go really far back. I mean, a lot of people in Britain, when they tell the story, they sort of assume that the violence just exploded out of nowhere and it was carried out by psychopathic extremists who were motivated by or exploiting ancient hatreds
所以我期待你效仿那个水平。哇，压力真大。所以实际上，即使是你从哪里开始讲这个故事，本身就是一个政治选择。没错，因为诺曼人的到来。没错，你可以追溯到很久以前。我的意思是，英国的许多人在讲述这个故事时，他们倾向于认为暴力是凭空爆发的，是由那些被古老仇恨所驱使或利用古老仇恨的心理变态极端分子所实施的，
and it's senseless, inexplicable, or all this kind of thing. Now, of course, if you're an Irish nationalist, you would start the story much earlier. You would say, well, you shouldn't start in the 1960s. You should start with, maybe with the Normans arriving in Ireland, maybe with Elizabeth I, First, Oliver Cromwell, the plantation of Ulster, the importation of tens of thousands of English and Scottish colonists. And they would say you should start the story there. Unfortunately, we no longer live in a world where the rest of history can do 13-part series,
而且是毫无意义的、无法解释的，诸如此类。现在，当然，如果你是一个爱尔兰民族主义者，你会从更早的时候开始讲这个故事。你会说，嗯，你不应该从20世纪60年代开始。你应该从诺曼人抵达爱尔兰开始，也许从伊丽莎白一世、奥利弗·克伦威尔、阿尔斯特种植园、成千上万的英国和苏格兰殖民者的输入开始。他们会说你应该从那里开始讲这个故事。不幸的是，我们不再生活在一个《历史的余味》可以制作13集系列节目的世界里了，
and we have done the story of Ireland before. So I think a sensible compromise is if we just pick up the story at the end of our last Irish series that we did, which is the early 20th century. For people who haven't heard this series, at the beginning of the 20th century, in 1900, there were about four and a half million people on the island of Ireland, and they are subjects of the United Kingdom. And most of them, three-quarters of them are Catholic, and a quarter of them are Protestant. and the Protestants are mostly concentrated in the northeastern part of the island,
而且我们之前已经讲过爱尔兰的故事了。所以我认为一个明智的折中方案是，我们从我们上一部爱尔兰系列节目的结尾，也就是20世纪初开始讲起。对于那些没有听过那个系列的人，在20世纪初，即1900年，爱尔兰岛上有大约450万人，他们是大英帝国的臣民。他们中的大多数，四分之三是天主教徒，四分之一是新教徒。新教徒主要集中在岛的东北部，
so that is in the province of Ulster and around the city, the industrial city of Belfast, a place where the Titanic was built. And if you want to hear more about that, we did a whole series about the Titanic and its origins in Belfast. And in the first 20 years or so the century, massive controversy about Ireland's political future, the nationalists who are mostly Catholic want home rule or independence, but the Unionists, who are typically Protestant, want to stay part of the United Kingdom. And the Unionists in the North East are so bitterly opposed to the prospect of Home Rule from Dublin in a Catholic-dominated island that in 1912, almost half a million of them, led by Sir Edward Carson,
也就是阿尔斯特省和工业城市贝尔法斯特周围，泰坦尼克号建造的地方。如果你想了解更多关于那方面的内容，我们制作了关于泰坦尼克号及其在贝尔法斯特起源的整个系列。在世纪的前20年左右，关于爱尔兰的政治未来存在巨大的争议，主要是天主教徒的民族主义者想要“地方自治”或独立，但通常是新教徒的统一派想要留在联合王国。东北部的统一派对未来在天主教主导的岛屿上接受来自都柏林的“地方自治”的前景感到极其反感，以至于在1912年，在爱德华·卡森爵士的领导下，近50万名统一派，
sign a covenant pledging to use all means necessary to fight against Home Rule. and the legacy of this will reverberate down the generations long into the 1970s and beyond. I suppose it kind of offers a historical precedent for paramilitary activity, doesn't it? Absolutely, it does. It's a kind of heroic model of, well, if you're not a paramilitary, you'd call it gangsterism. Yes, of course. And almost all of the paramilitaries we will meet in this series would look back to the events of the 1910s and 1920s and say, I'm doing as my forefathers did before me.
签署了一份盟约，承诺使用一切必要手段来反对“地方自治”。而这所带来的遗产将影响几代人，一直持续到20世纪70年代及以后。我想这为准军事活动提供了一种历史先例，不是吗？绝对是这样。这是一种英雄主义模式，嗯，如果你不是准军事人员，你会称之为黑帮主义。是的，当然。在本系列中我们将遇到的几乎所有准军事人员都会回顾1910年代和1920年代的事件，并说，我正在做我的祖先在我之前所做的事情。
So absolutely, the history really matters. 100,000 of these people who signed the covenant organized into the paramilitary volunteers, and they smuggled tens of thousands of guns into Ulster, and they were preparing for civil war. But then the First World War intervened. And a lot of the volunteers went off to fight, a lot of them fought at Gallipoli, or indeed at the Somme, which became a kind of sacred moment for the Protestants of Ulster, 1916. But also in 1916, at Easter, there was a nationalist uprising in Dublin. And that was followed by a guerrilla campaign, largely in the south of Ireland, the Catholic bits of Ireland, that undermined British authority completely. So, Dominique, I'm sure you've been to the Shankill Road and the Falls Road.
所以绝对的，历史真的很重要。这10万名签署盟约的人组织成了准军事志愿军，他们向阿尔斯特走私了数万支枪支，并为内战做准备。但随后第一次世界大战介入了。许多志愿者去参战了，许多人在加里波利，或者在索姆河战役中作战，这成为了阿尔斯特新教徒的一种神圣时刻，即1916年。但同样在1916年复活节，都柏林发生了一场民族主义起义。随后是一场游击战，主要是在爱尔兰南部，即爱尔兰的天主教地区，这彻底削弱了英国的权威。所以，多米尼克，我相信你去过尚基尔路（Shankill Road）和福尔斯路（Falls Road）。
So the Shackhill Road is the Protestant, you know, the street that runs through the Protestant Heartland of Belfast and the Falls Road is Catholic. They're separated now by peace walls, aren't they? Yeah. But if you, there are kind of Checkpoint Charlie type places where they join. And on one side, there are murals of the Battle of the Som, poppies, graveyards, British military heroes. Yes. And on the other side, all up the Falls Road, there are kind of murals of the Easter Rising. And it's like kind of the history is literally written onto the bricks.
尚基尔路是新教徒的，你知道，那是贯穿贝尔法斯特新教腹地的街道，而福尔斯路是天主教的。它们现在被和平墙隔开了，不是吗？是的。但如果你去的话，它们连接的地方有类似“查理检查站”的地方。在一边，有索姆河战役的壁画、罂粟花、墓地、英国军事英雄。是的。而在另一边，沿着福尔斯路，到处都是复活节起义的壁画。历史就像是真真切切地写在砖头上一样。
It is, absolutely. Two rival histories describing the same period, but in completely different terms. Exactly right. So anyway, back to the story. In 2022, the British agreed a treaty. that would turn Ireland into a free state, a dominion under the crown, and basically put it on the road to independence as a republic, which it becomes in 1949. But there was a catch.
确实如此。两段相互竞争的历史描述着同一个时期，但用词完全不同。完全正确。所以，回到故事。1922年，英国人签署了一项条约，将爱尔兰变成了一个自由邦，一个王权下的自治领，并基本上让它走上了通往共和国独立的道路，它在1949年成为了共和国。但有一个陷阱。
Two years earlier, the British had allowed six counties in the northeast to form a separate entity called Northern Ireland with its own parliament in Belfast. And the treaty that they do in 1922 allows this entity to opt out of the new free state and to remain as part of the United Kingdom. And the Parliament of Northern Ireland immediately says that's what it wants to do. And so this is what gives you the partition of the island of Ireland. Dominic, can I just ask, there was never any question that they would just become a kind of independent statelet? No, too small to be a statelet.
两年前，英国人允许东北部的六个郡组成一个独立的实体，称为北爱尔兰，并在贝尔法斯特拥有自己的议会。他们在1922年签署的条约允许这个实体选择退出新的自由邦，并作为联合王国的一部分保留下来。北爱尔兰议会立即表示这就是它想做的。所以这就是导致爱尔兰岛分裂的原因。多米尼克，我能问一下吗，有没有可能他们只是变成了一个类似独立的小国？不，太小了，成不了小国。
And dependence on money from Westminster. So this is a sort of theme that comes up again and again in the 70s, where British Prime Ministers will say, we're giving you all this money. Why can't you do what we want you to do? But it is a theme, isn't it also? the Protestants of Ulster don't really like Britain. Or they don't really like British governments. They like the idea of Britain but not the reality of British government, I think it's fair.
而且依赖于威斯敏斯特的资金。所以这是一个在70年代反复出现的主题，英国首相会说，我们给了你们这么多钱，为什么你们不能做我们想让你们做的事？但这也是一个主题，不是吗？阿尔斯特的新教徒并不真正喜欢英国。或者说他们并不真正喜欢英国政府。我认为公平地说，他们喜欢英国这个概念，而不是英国政府的现实。
So I think they think that British governments are not good at defending British interests and that they're better at it. And they regard the British as weak and they think the British don't understand their unique situation. Which I guess is kind of true to a degree. It is probably true. So anyway, the partition of Arna in the south, you have 26 counties, overwhelming Catholic majority, Capital in Dublin, this in 1949 becomes the Republic of Ireland. And then in the northeast, there are six counties, Northern Ireland, it's a self-governing bit of the United Kingdom, capital in Belfast, Parliament at Stormont on the Stormont estate in Belfast, and a two-thirds
所以我认为他们认为英国政府不擅长捍卫英国利益，而他们自己更擅长。他们认为英国人软弱，认为英国人不了解他们独特的处境。我想这在某种程度上是真的。这可能是真的。所以总之，爱尔兰的分裂，在南部，你有26个郡，绝大多数是天主教徒，首都在都柏林，这在1949年成为了爱尔兰共和国。然后在东北部，有六个郡，即北爱尔兰，它是联合王国的一个自治部分，首都在贝尔法斯特，议会在贝尔法斯特的斯托蒙特庄园，并且有三分之二的
Protestant majority. Now, Ian Paisley, in that reading, he called it Ulster, and lots of people do call it Ulster. Actually, it's only six of the nine historic counties of the province of Ulster. So this is a very good way to annoy Irish nationalists, if you call it Ulster, because they will point out, it's actually not all of Ulster. Every geographical expression in this story annoys people. It does indeed. So British Isles, Ireland, whatever. I mean, always pregnant with annoyance for everyone. Every name is a choice, basically. And I'm sure there were lots of people who say,
新教徒多数。现在，伊恩·佩斯利在刚才的朗读中称它为阿尔斯特，很多人确实称它为阿尔斯特。实际上，它只是阿尔斯特省九个历史郡中的六个。所以如果你称它为阿尔斯特，这是一个激怒爱尔兰民族主义者的好方法，因为他们会指出，它实际上并不是整个阿尔斯特。这个故事中的每一个地理表达都会激怒人们。确实如此。所以“不列颠群岛”、“爱尔兰”，无论什么。我的意思是，总是充满了让每个人恼火的因素。每一个名字基本上都是一种选择。而且我相信有很多人会说，
well, you got this wrong, you should have said this, you should have said the other. I mean, we're going to try our best. And I speak as the man who uttered the word Londonderry in the Dublin, in the Dublin GPO. Yeah, you corrected Paul Rouse when we did a series about Ireland. He corrected a professor of history at University College Dublin. I was just, you know, stricken up for Ulster. Yeah, you were, reminding him that there are two words for it.
嗯，你弄错了，你应该说这个，你应该说那个。我的意思是，我们会尽力而为。而且我是那个在都柏林邮政总局（GPO）说出“伦敦德里”（Londonderry）这个词的人。是的，当我们制作关于爱尔兰的系列节目时，你纠正了保罗·劳斯。你纠正了一位都柏林大学学院的历史学教授。我只是，你知道，为阿尔斯特挺身而出。是的，你提醒他，它有两个名字。
Ian Paisley would have been proud of you. So, to nationalists, partition is the original sin of modern Irish history, a blight that should be rectified. I think most historians, including most Irish historians, would agree that partition was probably inevitable. That basically, once the Ulster volunteers had, you know, as it were, signed their covenant, they'd armed themselves. They were never going to be forced into a United Island without a civil war. And basically that was the choice. You partition the island, or it all kicks off and you have a civil war.
伊恩·佩斯利会为你感到骄傲的。所以，对于民族主义者来说，分裂是现代爱尔兰历史的原罪，是一个应该被纠正的污点。我认为大多数历史学家，包括大多数爱尔兰历史学家，都会同意分裂可能是不可避免的。基本上，一旦阿尔斯特志愿军签署了他们的盟约，他们就武装了自己。如果没有内战，他们永远不会被迫加入一个统一的爱尔兰。基本上这就是选择。你要么分裂这个岛，要么一切爆发，你陷入内战。
But even if you had a civil war, what do you do? Yeah, where are they going to go? There's, you know, a million people or whatever it is. With guns? Yeah. I mean, that's not good. No. So at the time when Ireland was partitioned, I think a lot of nationalists just assumed that over time it would wither away. Partition would wither away. The six counties one day would agree to join a United Ireland. It was their destiny. And obviously that didn't work out. Northern Ireland as an entity proved much more resilient than they had expected. But that said, from the start, there's a serious fracture line that runs through Northern Ireland. So the union's leaders, when they basically, took six counties. They had guaranteed themselves a two-thirds Protestant majority. They could
但即使你陷入内战，你该怎么办？是的，他们要去哪里？那里有，你知道，一百万人还是多少。带着枪？是的。我的意思是，那不好。不。所以当爱尔兰分裂时，我想很多民族主义者只是认为随着时间的推移，它会逐渐消失。分裂会逐渐消失。六个郡有一天会同意加入一个统一的爱尔兰。这是他们的命运。显然这并没有实现。北爱尔兰作为一个实体被证明比他们预期的要坚韧得多。但话虽如此，从一开始，北爱尔兰就存在一条严重的断裂线。所以统一派领导人在他们基本上拿走六个郡时，他们已经保证了自己三分之二的新教徒多数。他们可以
have asked for more counties, but of course those counties had a lot of Catholics. They didn't want them. So they've got their two-thirds majority. So they're gerrymanding. I mean, you could say effectively, yes. Yeah. But what that means, of course, is that one-third of the people in this new state are not Protestants. They are Catholics. So this is half a million people who are not best pleased at the idea of living in a majority Protestant, unionist state. And partly as a result of this, this whole process was accompanied at the time by considerable violence. Now, the early 20s is a very violent time across Europe. There are all kinds of ethnic conflicts and there are border disputes and all of these kinds of things.
要求更多的郡，但当然那些郡有很多天主教徒。他们不想要他们。所以他们得到了三分之二的多数。所以他们在进行杰利蝾螈式的选区划分。我的意思是，你可以说实际上是这样。是的。但这意味着，当然，这个新国家三分之一的人口不是新教徒。他们是天主教徒。所以这是50万人，他们对生活在一个以新教徒、统一派为主的国家感到非常不高兴。部分由于这个结果，整个过程在当时伴随着相当大的暴力。现在，20年代是整个欧洲非常暴力的时期。有各种各样的种族冲突，有边界争端，所有这些事情。
And by those standards, not a lot of people die, but by the standards of the islands of Britain and Ireland, a lot of people do die. So between the summer of 1920 and the summer of 1922, there's this intense street fighting between the IRA and the security. forces, especially in Belfast. By the time it's over, more than 500 people have been killed, most of them Catholic civilians, 10,000 Catholics driven out of their jobs, 25,000 Catholics driven out of their homes by violence and by arson and so on and so forth. I mean, one difference between Ireland and other parts of Europe in the wake of the First World War, that the violence in Ireland is kind of, it's a continuity.
按照那些标准，死亡的人数并不多，但按照英国和爱尔兰岛的标准，确实有很多人死亡。所以在1920年夏天到1922年夏天之间，爱尔兰共和军（IRA）和安全部队之间发生了激烈的街头战斗，特别是在贝尔法斯特。当它结束时，超过500人被杀，其中大多数是天主教平民，1万名天主教徒被赶出工作岗位，2.5万名天主教徒因暴力、纵火等原因被赶出家园。我的意思是，第一次世界大战后爱尔兰与其他欧洲地区的一个区别是，爱尔兰的暴力是一种连续性。
And Churchill has that kind of famous phrase about the flood, isn't it? And as the water subside, we see the dreary steeples of Farr Manor and Tyrone. They're still there. And that, I guess, is part of what gives the story around this the sense of ancient hatreds. The idea that there's no solution to the situation. Well, to some extent, people are the prisoners of history and the stories they tell, and the lessons they learn when they're children. And you have generations of people who have grown.
丘吉尔有句关于洪水的那句名言，不是吗？随着水退去，我们看到了法马纳郡和蒂龙郡阴郁的尖塔。它们还在那里。我想，这就是赋予这个故事周围那种古老仇恨感的部分原因。那种认为这种情况没有解决办法的想法。嗯，在某种程度上，人们是历史和他们所讲述的故事，以及他们小时候学到的教训的囚徒。你有几代人成长起来，
up being told stories of separatism, of separate identity, of antagonism and so on. History is woven into the texture of life in Northern Ireland. It will come to the parades, the marches, the celebrations of battles of the 17th century and things. I mean, it really, really matters and it cannot simply be put aside or wished away. I mean, and that's one of the lessons of this story. That continuity kind of gives you a context that people find it very difficult to escape, I suppose. But also that politicians in London view this with a kind of frustrated sense of battlement, which is kind of what Churchill is saying there. Nothing has changed.
被告知关于分裂主义、独立身份、对抗等等的故事。历史被编织进了北爱尔兰生活的肌理中。我们会谈到游行、行军、对17世纪战役的庆祝等等。我的意思是，它真的、真的很重要，不能简单地被搁置或被希望消失。我的意思是，这也是这个故事的教训之一。那种连续性提供了一种人们发现很难逃脱的背景，我想。但也因为伦敦的政客们以一种沮丧的无能感来看待这个问题，这正是丘吉尔在那里所说的。什么都没有改变。
No, exactly. And in fact, the longer time goes on. And the more that the Irish question as it were, which had been so big in the late 19th century, the more that it recedes, the less that people in London understand it. So by the time you get to the 60s and 70s, you have a generation of politicians in London. Take someone like James Callaghan. We'll talk about him later on. He was the grandson of somebody who had left Ireland in the famine, but his family had ended up converting from Catholicism to baptism.
不，完全正确。事实上，随着时间的推移，爱尔兰问题——在19世纪末曾如此重要——越是消退，伦敦的人们就越不理解它。所以当你到了60年代和70年代，你有一代伦敦的政客。以詹姆斯·卡拉汉为例。我们稍后会谈到他。他是大饥荒时期离开爱尔兰的人的孙子，但他的家庭最终从天主教改信了浸信会。
Does James Callahan understand Ireland? No, not really. He's not really interested in it. It's something that happened a long time ago to him. But to people in Belfast, this is going to living history. It's real. And the fact that the British don't understand it is enraging to them because it matters so much to them. Anyway, back to the state of Northern Ireland.
詹姆斯·卡拉汉了解爱尔兰吗？不，并不真正了解。他对此并不真正感兴趣。对他来说，那是很久以前发生的事情。但对贝尔法斯特的人来说，这是活生生的历史。它是真实的。而且英国人不理解这一事实让他们感到愤怒，因为它对他们来说太重要了。总之，回到北爱尔兰的状态。
All this fighting in the early 20s had two obvious consequences. First of all, if you're part of the one-third Catholic minority, you do not regard this state as a safe space by any means. It's actually a very unsafe space for you. Is there emigration? There is some emigration. Yes, there are thousands of people who cross the border to the Republic. Again, by the standards of European population transfers to the 20s, it's not enormous, but it's not nothing. There are people who definitely move south because they think this is going to be a very unwelcoming place for us.
20年代初的所有这些战斗有两个明显的后果。首先，如果你是三分之一天主教少数群体的一部分，你绝不会认为这个国家是一个安全的空间。它实际上对你来说是一个非常不安全的空间。有移民吗？确实有一些移民。是的，有成千上万的人越过边界去了共和国。同样，按照20年代欧洲人口转移的标准，它并不巨大，但也不是没有。确实有人搬到了南方，因为他们认为这对我们来说将是一个非常不友好的地方。
And Protestants moving from the south to the north? Not so much, more so that Protestants, I think, would move from the south to Britain. Right, okay. Here are people who lived in the big houses, the Anglo-Irish kind of Protestant ascendancy and so on. So obviously, if you're Catholic, there are loads of families who sort of bear the scars, sometimes physically of the fighting. There are a lot of people, actually later on, who were involved in the IRA or whatever in the 60s and 70s, who had parents and grandparents who had told them stories about what happened in 1920 or 1921.
那么新教徒从南方搬到北方呢？没那么多，更多的是新教徒，我想，会从南方搬到英国。对，好的。这里住着住在豪宅里的人，盎格鲁-爱尔兰那种新教徒统治阶级等等。所以很明显，如果你是天主教徒，有很多家庭会承受战斗留下的伤痕，有时是身体上的。实际上，后来在60年代和70年代参与爱尔兰共和军等组织的人中，有很多人，他们的父母和祖父母曾告诉过他们1920年或1921年发生的事情。
But then for Protestants, for the Protestant majority, they don't regard this as an entirely safe space either. Because although they are a majority in their own state, they are not a majority on the island. They feel we're surrounded by Catholics, we're besieged by Catholics, there is a state to the south that aspires to a united Ireland so that wishes us ill and wants to destroy our state. That's how they see it. And they say, we've also got this fifth column inside our own borders. We've got a third of our population are Catholics and we can't trust them. And is there anxiety at this stage about the demographic potential of Catholic families tending to have more children than Protestant families?
但对于新教徒，对于新教徒多数派来说，他们也不认为这是一个完全安全的空间。因为虽然他们在自己的国家是多数，但他们在岛上不是多数。他们觉得我们被天主教徒包围了，我们被天主教徒围困了，南方有一个国家渴望统一的爱尔兰，所以它对我们怀有恶意，想要摧毁我们的国家。这就是他们的看法。他们说，我们自己的边界内也有这个“第五纵队”。我们三分之一的人口是天主教徒，我们不能信任他们。那么在这个阶段，对于天主教家庭倾向于比新教家庭生更多孩子的人口潜力，是否有焦虑？
Which is a kind of people talk about that a lot now. Yeah. Was it an issue back then? People talked about it a lot. They talked about it a lot throughout the 20th century. So Terence O'Neill, who is the Northern Ireland Prime Minister in the 60s, made a very very contentious speech at the end of the decade when he said, and he disregarded as him being too soft by a lot of Eunists, he said, we should treat the Catholics more nicely
这是一种人们现在经常谈论的事情。是的。当时这是一个问题吗？人们谈论了很多。他们在整个20世纪都谈论了很多。所以特伦斯·奥尼尔，60年代的北爱尔兰总理，在十年末发表了一次非常、非常有争议的演讲，他说——他被许多统一派视为太软弱——他说，我们应该对天主教徒更友善一些，
because they have loads and loads of children. And if we treat them more nicely, they will behave better and they will have fewer children and they won't overtake us demographically. Basically, nobody likes this speech. There's quite a lot to unpick there. Yeah, there's a lot going on. But yeah, absolutely. People often would talk about that. I mean, I don't think it's that they feel demographically we're going to be overwhelmed very quickly. What they feel is the people in Dublin want to undermine us,
因为他们生了很多很多孩子。如果我们对他们更友善，他们会表现得更好，他们会生更少的孩子，他们就不会在人口统计上超过我们。基本上，没人喜欢这个演讲。这里有很多东西需要剖析。是的，有很多事情在发生。但是的，绝对的。人们经常会谈论这个。我的意思是，我不认为他们觉得在人口统计上我们很快就会被淹没。他们觉得的是都柏林的人想要破坏我们，
which a lot of them frankly do. They think, they look south and they say, well, this newly, effectively autonomous and going to be independent Ireland is turning itself into a kind of Catholic-run state with the church having overweening power. This is the one thing we dread. We don't want this.
坦率地说，他们中的许多人确实如此。他们认为，他们看向南方，他们说，嗯，这个新成立的、实际上自治且即将独立的爱尔兰正在把自己变成一个由天主教管理的国家，教会拥有过度的权力。这是我们最恐惧的一件事。我们不想要这个。
And we have all these people within our own borders who we don't think we can trust, who would like to, you know, who would like to undermine us. So that's why, I mean, there's a defensiveness that gives you the slogan, no surrender, which is, of course, one of Ian Paisley's favorite phrases, isn't it? Yeah. So those tensions. So they're there in the 20s. And then when most people in Britain tell the story, they sort of stop there and they, if I say,
而且我们自己的边界内有所有这些人，我们认为我们不能信任他们，他们想要，你知道，他们想要破坏我们。所以这就是为什么，我的意思是，有一种防御心理，产生了“绝不投降”（No Surrender）这个口号，这当然是伊恩·佩斯利最喜欢的短语之一，不是吗？是的。所以那些紧张局势。所以它们在20年代就存在了。然后当英国的大多数人讲述这个故事时，他们就在那里停下来，如果我说，
well, let's fast forward to the 1960s, because kind of nothing happens in between. But that's actually dead wrong. Lots of stuff happens in between. It's just we don't ever learn about it in Britain. So, for example, in 1935, I mean, this will surprise loads of people. There is massive rioting in Belfast. There are gun battles. There are snipers on the top of buildings.
嗯，让我们快进到20世纪60年代，因为中间基本上什么都没发生。但这实际上是大错特错。中间发生了很多事情。只是我们在英国从来没有学过它。例如，在1935年，我的意思是，这会让很多人感到惊讶。贝尔法斯特发生了大规模骚乱。有枪战。建筑物顶部有狙击手。
British troops have to be sent to clear the streets with armoured cars. 11 people are killed, 100 people injured. 2,000 people are driven out of their homes. And then actually, that inspired reprisals across the Irish border. So there were attacks on Protestant homes and shops in Limerick. There were burnings of Church of Ireland churches. and Methodist chapels and rural Ireland and so on and so forth. And in the background, the whole time, the Irish Republican Army,
英国军队不得不被派去用装甲车清理街道。11人死亡，100人受伤。2000人被赶出家园。然后实际上，这引发了爱尔兰边境的报复行动。所以利默里克发生了针对新教徒家庭和商店的袭击。爱尔兰农村发生了爱尔兰教会教堂和卫理公会礼拜堂的焚烧事件等等。而在背景中，整个时间里，爱尔兰共和军，
so there's been all this stuff in the 1910s and 1920s with the IRA, the IRA had split in Southern Ireland. It had, in what became the Republic, it had fought a civil war. The IRA never went away. It's still there all this time. So most IRA men, once the British signed the treaty and the civil war was over, they did go home. They put their guns away. That was an end to it. But not all of them did. So at any given point, there are still a few hundred active IRA men with guns, and that is still enough to kill people. And they do kill people. So in January 1939, again, most people in Britain don't know this happened. In January 1939, the IRA launched a new campaign against Britain, and they called it the S plan, the sabotage plan. And when you go, I mean, it's astounding how little known the this is when you go through what happened. There were bombs in London and Birmingham, Bristol,
所以1910年代和1920年代有所有这些关于爱尔兰共和军的事情，爱尔兰共和军在爱尔兰南部发生了分裂。它在后来成为共和国的地方，打了一场内战。爱尔兰共和军从来没有消失。它一直都在。所以大多数爱尔兰共和军成员，一旦英国人签署了条约，内战结束，他们确实回家了。他们放下了枪。那是结束了。但并不是所有人都这样。所以无论在什么时候，仍然有几百名带着枪的活跃爱尔兰共和军成员，这仍然足以杀人。而且他们确实杀了人。所以在1939年1月，同样，英国的大多数人不知道这件事发生了。1939年1月，爱尔兰共和军对英国发动了一场新的运动，他们称之为“S计划”，即破坏计划。当你去，我的意思是，当你经历所发生的事情时，这件事鲜为人知是令人震惊的。伦敦、伯明翰、布里斯托尔发生了炸弹袭击，
in Liverpool, and Blackpool all over. There were bomb attacks on railway stations, banks, post office. There were bombs on the London Underground. Most notoriously, there was a bicycle bomb in Coventry City Centre in August 1939 that killed five people, the youngest of whom was 50 in the oldest 82. I mean, I suppose that further developments in Coventry City Centre, the following year have slightly obliterated the memory of that bomb. Yeah, of course, isn't it funny that commentary is, you know, obviously bombed by the Germans, everyone remembers that. So this 1939 bombing, which otherwise would be very, you know, very well known.
利物浦和布莱克浦到处都是。火车站、银行、邮局发生了炸弹袭击。伦敦地铁上有炸弹。最臭名昭著的是，1939年8月考文垂市中心发生了一起自行车炸弹袭击，造成5人死亡，其中最年轻的50岁，最年长的82岁。我的意思是，我想考文垂市中心随后的发展在某种程度上抹去了对那枚炸弹的记忆。是的，当然，考文垂被德国人轰炸，每个人都记得这一点，这不是很滑稽吗？所以这次1939年的爆炸，如果不是这样，会非常，你知道，非常出名。
Very salient, yeah. It's basically been wiped from our national consciousness. But what happens to the IRA? In World War II, both the British and the Irish government's massively cracked down, and they started interning IRA suspects without trial. Ireland actually executed six IRA men during the Second World War, including the chief of staff of the IRA. They executed him for killing a guard, an Irish policeman. So the Irish are just as tough on the IRA as the British are.
非常显著，是的。它基本上已经从我们的民族意识中抹去了。但爱尔兰共和军发生了什么？在第二次世界大战中，英国和爱尔兰政府都进行了大规模的镇压，他们开始在没有审判的情况下拘留爱尔兰共和军嫌疑人。爱尔兰在第二次世界大战期间实际上处决了六名爱尔兰共和军成员，包括爱尔兰共和军的总参谋长。他们处决他是因为他杀了一名卫兵，一名爱尔兰警察。所以爱尔兰人对爱尔兰共和军的强硬程度和英国人一样。
Now, against this background, the people who run Northern Ireland, the unionists, have absolutely no intention of loosening their grip. And the first Prime Minister of Northern Ireland was called Sir James Craig. If you look, Google him, he really does like a boiled air. and someone has painted a face on him. Does he have a massive moustache? He does have a moustache, yeah. Of course he does. I mean, with the name like Sir James Craig, you couldn't not.
现在，在这种背景下，管理北爱尔兰的人，即统一派，完全没有打算放松他们的控制。北爱尔兰的第一任总理叫詹姆斯·克雷格爵士。如果你看，谷歌一下他，他看起来真的很像一个煮熟的蛋，有人在他脸上画了一个表情。他有巨大的胡子吗？他确实有胡子，是的。他当然有。我的意思是，有着詹姆斯·克雷格爵士这样的名字，你不可能没有。
He undoubtedly has moustache, yeah, no question. So he was very explicit about this. He gave a speech in the 1930s. He said, I'm not going to do the accent because my Northern Irish accent is not as good as yours. He said, in the South, they boast of being a Catholic state. All I boast of is that we are a Protestant parliament and a Protestant state. That's good, Dominic.
他无疑有胡子，是的，毫无疑问。所以他对此非常明确。他在20世纪30年代发表了一次演讲。他说，我不会模仿口音，因为我的北爱尔兰口音不如你的好。他说，在南方，他们吹嘘自己是一个天主教国家。我所吹嘘的只是我们是一个新教议会和一个新教国家。那很好，多米尼克。
Thank you. It's understated, though, and it's a bit wobbly. He's not wrong. They are a Protestant state. The judges, the magistrates, the civil servants are almost entirely Protestant. The Royal Ulster Constabulary, the RUC, the police, who can play a massive part in this story, they're about nine to one Protestant. And the RUC has an armed kind of paramilitary reserve called the B specials that people sign up for. And these are exclusively Protestant, really.
谢谢。不过这很低调，而且有点摇晃。他没说错。他们是一个新教国家。法官、地方法官、公务员几乎全是新教徒。皇家阿尔斯特警队（RUC），即警察，在这个故事中扮演了重要角色，他们大约九比一都是新教徒。而且RUC有一个武装的准军事预备队，叫做“B特种部队”（B Specials），人们报名参加。这些基本上是专门的新教徒。
They are the sort of the bulwark, the enforcers of unionist supremacy. When things kick off in the streets, you call for the B specials, and they come out of their orange order lodges with their guns, and they are the people who will basically restore order. So in the 70s and 80s, the comparison was often made between Northern Ireland and South Africa by nationalists and Republicans. But, I mean, there's kind of an element of truth there, isn't there, to a degree? It's a very inflammatory comparison. I mean, if the entire apparatus of the state is controlled by one faction, then it's not, I mean, there's no way you could describe it as a properly functioning democracy.
他们是统一派至上主义的堡垒，是执行者。当街头发生冲突时，你呼叫“B特种部队”，他们带着枪从他们的奥兰治兄弟会会所出来，他们基本上就是恢复秩序的人。所以在70年代和80年代，民族主义者和共和党人经常将北爱尔兰与南非进行比较。但是，我的意思是，在某种程度上，这确实有一定道理，不是吗？这是一个非常煽动性的比较。我的意思是，如果国家的所有机构都由一个派系控制，那么它就不是，我的意思是，你不可能把它描述为一个正常运作的民主国家。
No, no, you absolutely couldn't. We'll come on to this. You absolutely couldn't. And it's overtly sectarian. If not, I mean, it's not, it's not racist, but it's sectarian. It's not racist. It is a sectarian state. Exactly. And Sir James Craig or somebody at that would say, I mean, he might quibble with the word sectarian, but he would say, you know, we're a Protestant state. End a story. If you don't like it, go somewhere else. This is how we're going to run things. You know, we know what we're doing. Pipe down. He would absolutely say that.
不，不，你绝对不能。我们稍后会谈到这一点。你绝对不能。而且它是公开的宗派主义。如果不是，我的意思是，它不是，它不是种族主义，但它是宗派主义。它不是种族主义。它是一个宗派国家。完全正确。詹姆斯·克雷格爵士或类似的人会说，我的意思是，他可能会对“宗派”这个词吹毛求疵，但他会说，你知道，我们是一个新教国家。故事结束。如果你不喜欢它，去别的地方。这就是我们做事的方式。你知道，我们知道我们在做什么。闭嘴。他绝对会这么说。
And critics would say, well, that's what the Afrikaners or whatever say in South Africa. Some people in Northern Ireland would be offended by that. Some people would lean into that comparison, say, well, we kind of are like the birds. We are hardy frontiersmen. We've carved out of state in the face of overwhelming odds. You know, we've built something really precious and special and we want to defend it, and don't you tell us what to do?
而批评者会说，嗯，这就是南非的阿非利卡人或其他人所说的。北爱尔兰的一些人会对此感到被冒犯。有些人会倾向于那种比较，说，嗯，我们有点像布尔人。我们是坚韧的边疆开拓者。我们在压倒性的困难面前开辟了一个国家。你知道，我们建立了一些非常珍贵和特别的东西，我们想要捍卫它，别告诉我们该怎么做。
I don't want to plunge into this because it's murky waters, but on the Shank Hill and Falls Road murals, the Shankhill is full of the Israeli flag and the Falls Road is full of the Palestinian flag. Absolutely right. Absolutely. Yes. There is a self-image. The unionist, especially some years ago, would have said, we are like the chosen people, we're like the children of God, the children of Zion, or. of that kind of thing. Well, I mean, in Paisley definitely would have done. Ian Paisley undoubtedly would. And of course, among nationalists, their comparison with the Palestinians, you know, dates, goes back to the 70s. So absolutely, yes.
我不想深入探讨这个问题，因为这水太浑了，但在尚基尔路（Shank Hill）和福尔斯路（Falls Road）的壁画上，尚基尔路到处都是以色列国旗，而福尔斯路到处都是巴勒斯坦国旗。完全正确。绝对是。是的。这是一种自我形象。统一派，特别是在几年前，会说我们就像上帝的选民，我们就像上帝的孩子，锡安的孩子，或者类似的东西。我的意思是，佩斯利（Paisley）肯定会这么做。伊恩·佩斯利（Ian Paisley）无疑会。当然，在民族主义者中，他们与巴勒斯坦人的比较可以追溯到70年代。所以绝对是这样。
Two things about the IAC of the police, which is important for people to remember. Number one, they are much, much more powerful than a police force in Britain or elsewhere in Western Europe. There was special legislation in 1922 that gave them special powers. They can search without a warrants. They can arrest you without a warrant. They can intern you as a suspect. without trial, they can impose a curfew, a ban on a march or a ban on a newspaper at will.
关于警察的IAC，有两点人们必须记住，这很重要。第一，他们比英国或其他西欧国家的警察部队强大得多。1922年有一项特别立法赋予了他们特殊权力。他们可以在没有搜查令的情况下进行搜查。他们可以在没有逮捕令的情况下逮捕你。他们可以以嫌疑人的身份将你拘留，无需审判，他们可以随意实施宵禁，禁止游行或查封报纸。
So they have a lot of leeway. And the RUC, like their political masters, are very closely tied to a group called the Orange Order. And the Orange Order is basically a fraternal organisation, a fraternity, a brotherhood. It was founded in 1795. It was dedicated to the defence of Protestantism and the Union with Britain. It's of course named after William of Orange from the Glorious Revolution. And almost every single member of the B Special Reserves and almost every single unionist MP is an Orangeman, belongs to an orange lodge. So where does that leave you if you're a Catholic?
所以他们有很大的回旋余地。而且皇家阿尔斯特警察队（RUC）和他们的政治主子一样，与一个叫“奥兰治兄弟会”（Orange Order）的组织联系非常紧密。奥兰治兄弟会基本上是一个兄弟会组织。它成立于1795年。它致力于捍卫新教和与英国的联合。它当然是以光荣革命中的奥兰治亲王威廉命名的。几乎每一个“B特种预备队”（B Special Reserves）的成员和几乎每一个统一派议员都是奥兰治兄弟会成员，都属于一个奥兰治分会。那么，如果你是天主教徒，这让你处于什么境地呢？
In 1967, the Times did a big investigation into the status of Catholics in Northern Ireland. And it described them as Ulster's second-class citizens. And actually you can see why. So the Ulster Unionist leader David Trimble, who ended up winning the Nobel Prize, didn't he, in 1998 in his Nobel Prize winning speech, said that Ulster Unionists, fearful of being isolated on the island,
1967年，《泰晤士报》对北爱尔兰天主教徒的地位进行了一次大规模调查。它将他们描述为阿尔斯特的二等公民。实际上你可以看出原因。所以，最终获得诺贝尔奖的阿尔斯特统一党领袖大卫·特林布尔（David Trimble），他在1998年的诺贝尔奖获奖演说中说，阿尔斯特统一派因为害怕在岛上被孤立，
built a solid house, but it was a cold house for Catholics, which was a sort of, a big concession for an Ulster Unionist leader to have said. And he was right. A lot of Protestant firms will not employ Catholics. If you have a Catholic name, if your name was, I don't know, Liam O'Hara or something, you probably would not get a job. You wouldn't even be interviewed for a job, given a chance of a job in the big Harland and Wolf shipyards.
建造了一座坚固的房子，但对天主教徒来说，这是一座寒冷的房子，这对于一位阿尔斯特统一党领袖来说是一个巨大的让步。他是对的。许多新教公司不会雇用天主教徒。如果你有一个天主教名字，如果你的名字是，我不知道，利亚姆·奥哈拉（Liam O'Hara）之类的，你可能找不到工作。你甚至不会得到面试机会，更不用说在哈兰德与沃尔夫（Harland and Wolf）造船厂获得工作的机会了。
Roman Catholics are twice as likely to be unemployed as Protestants, and they have no political power really, because Northern Ireland has a first-past-the-post political system in which the boundaries have been ruthlessly gerrymandered to ensure a permanent unionist majority at Stormont at the Parliament. This is even more glaring at the local level. at the local level, you can only vote if you're a ratepayer, if you pay local government rates, and you pay them if you own your own house, or if you rent a house, or you can vote if you're the spouse of somebody who, you know, the wife usually, of somebody who owns or rents a house. Now, Catholics are poorer. They're more likely to live in extended family groups or with their parents.
罗马天主教徒失业的可能性是新教徒的两倍，而且他们实际上没有任何政治权力，因为北爱尔兰实行的是“胜者全得”的政治制度，其选区边界被无情地操纵，以确保统一派在斯托蒙特（Stormont）议会中拥有永久多数席位。这在地方层面更为明显。在地方层面，只有纳税人才能投票，如果你缴纳地方政府税，如果你拥有自己的房子，或者如果你租房子，你就可以投票，或者如果你是拥有或租房者（通常是妻子）的配偶，你也可以投票。现在，天主教徒更穷。他们更有可能生活在大家庭中或与父母住在一起。
And as a result, lots of Catholics can't vote in local elections. as a result of that, in the cities or the places where you have a Catholic majority, so the city of Derry or County Tyrone or County Fermanagh, power is still controlled by the unionists because they have more people who own their own homes. And that means they control public jobs and crucially housing. It may sound very banal, but it's a massive deal in this story. Because the housing stock in Northern Ireland is terrible. It's really, it's Victorian, it's crumbling, you know, warning.
结果，许多天主教徒无法在地方选举中投票。因此，在天主教占多数的城市或地区，比如德里市（Derry）或蒂龙郡（County Tyrone）或弗马纳郡（County Fermanagh），权力仍然由统一派控制，因为他们拥有更多拥有自己住房的人。这意味着他们控制着公共职位，更关键的是，控制着住房。这听起来可能很平庸，但在这段故事中，这是一个巨大的问题。因为北爱尔兰的住房存量非常糟糕。它真的很破旧，是维多利亚时代的，正在崩塌，你知道，警告。
three houses, either doesn't have running water or it doesn't have a flushing toilet. So young couples in particular, they want to get out of their parents kind of crumbling Victorian terrace and they want a new home of their own. But because giving people a home means giving them votes, unionist councils don't like giving homes to Catholics because it gives them two more votes, right, husband and wife, if it's a young couple. So they don't like building homes in Catholic areas. Right. Yeah.
三栋房子，要么没有自来水，要么没有抽水马桶。所以年轻夫妇特别想搬出父母那种摇摇欲坠的维多利亚式排屋，他们想要一个属于自己的新家。但因为给人们房子就意味着给他们选票，统一派议会不喜欢给天主教徒提供住房，因为这会给他们多两张选票，对吧，如果是年轻夫妇，就是丈夫和妻子。所以他们不喜欢在天主教地区建房。对。是的。
The chairman of Enniskilling Housing Committee, 1963, we're going to see that the right people are put in these houses. We're not going to apologize for it. Now, it does work the other way around. So in Nationalist Councils, like Nuri, they built lots of new houses in the early sixes, and they gave only a tiny handful of them to Protestants. But the big losers from all this are the Catholics,
恩尼斯基林（Enniskilling）住房委员会主席在1963年说，我们要确保合适的人住进这些房子。我们不会为此道歉。现在，反过来也是一样的。所以，在像纽里（Nuri）这样的民族主义者议会中，他们在60年代初建造了许多新房子，他们只把其中极少数给了新教徒。但所有这些做法的最大输家是天主教徒，
and one place above all becomes emblematic of this. And this is the second city of Northern Ireland. A city in the far west of the country. It was originally a settlement called Derry. Then in 1613, a consortium of London guilds, basically, was set up to colonise the area. They built a new walled city. And because they were London guilds, they called it London Derry. And hence, you have the name controversy, which actually, in this period, the 60s.
而有一个地方最能代表这一点。这就是北爱尔兰的第二大城市。一个位于该国最西端的城市。它最初是一个叫德里（Derry）的定居点。然后在1613年，一个伦敦行会财团基本上被建立起来以殖民该地区。他们建造了一座新的围墙城市。因为他们是伦敦行会，他们称之为伦敦德里（Londonderry）。因此，就有了名称争议，实际上，在这一时期，即60年代。
Isn't really, is it? Everyone calls it Derry. Everybody calls it Derry. Yeah. It only really became a big. controversy once the troubles kicked off and then it became a kind of a point of pride to call it either derry like paul rouse our former guest or london dairy as you did in the general post office in dublin so so we'll just call it dairy for sure dairy in 1965 or so is a two to one catholic city so 36,000 Catholics are 18,000 Protestants but it's always been controlled by Protestants through gerrymandering so they're all always redrawing the boundaries of the wards to give themselves a majority on the council.
其实并不是，对吧？每个人都叫它德里。每个人都叫它德里。是的。只有在动乱开始后，它才真正成为一个大争议，然后称呼它为“德里”（像我们以前的嘉宾保罗·劳斯那样）或者像你在都柏林邮政总局那样称呼它为“伦敦德里”，就成了一种自豪感。所以，我们还是叫它德里吧。1965年左右的德里是一个天主教徒与新教徒比例为二比一的城市，即36,000名天主教徒对18,000名新教徒，但它一直通过选区划分操纵由新教徒控制，所以他们总是重新划分选区边界，以确保自己在议会中占多数。
So when I was thinking about this, I wondered whether you would say, surely the British government wouldn't stand for this. This is outrageous. But the truth as we shall see is the British have absolutely no interest on what happens in Northern Ireland at all. I appreciate that. I'm just wondering if it is under British law illegal. A good question. I don't think it is. Some Catholic solicitor would have undoubtedly taken its court. It's not illegal, I think, because the council set the boundaries. the councils decide the ward boundaries.
所以当我在思考这个问题时，我想知道你会不会说，英国政府肯定不会容忍这一点。这太离谱了。但正如我们将要看到的，事实是英国人对北爱尔兰发生的事情根本没有任何兴趣。我明白这一点。我只是想知道这在英国法律下是否违法。好问题。我不认为它是违法的。如果违法，一些天主教律师无疑会把它告上法庭。我认为它不违法，因为议会设定了边界，议会决定了选区边界。
So this is the devolution that Andy Burnham wants back. The right of councils to gerrymander. Right, which you'll see. Anyway, so to go back to Derry, basically almost every Protestant family who wants a house gets one, but there are 2,000 Catholic families on the waiting list for housing. And we will come back to this in the next episode because it is no accident that this is where the troubles really kick off
所以这就是安迪·伯纳姆（Andy Burnham）想要收回的权力下放。议会操纵选区的权利。对，你会看到的。总之，回到德里，基本上每个想要房子的新教家庭都能得到一套，但有2000个天主教家庭在住房等待名单上。我们将在下一集回到这个问题，因为动乱真正开始于此绝非偶然。
in earnest against this background. So just to finish by talking about the Catholics before we go to the break. Imagine, Tom, you're a young Catholic in the early 60s in Northern Ireland. What is your name? Seamus O. Murphy. Yeah, Seamus, whatever, exactly. So you're identifiable by your name. You have no flat.
在这种背景下真正开始。所以在我们休息之前，先谈谈天主教徒。想象一下，汤姆，你是60年代初北爱尔兰的一名年轻天主教徒。你叫什么名字？谢默斯·奥·墨菲（Seamus O. Murphy）。是的，谢默斯，随便什么，完全正确。所以你的名字就能让你被识别出来。你没有公寓。
You have no vote in local elections. You maybe don't have a job. You feel that the system is stacked against you, and it has been for the last 40 years. where do you look for hope? The Virgin Mary. Yeah, you probably may be to the Virgin Mary, exactly. You might look to the sort of Northern Irish Nationalist Party, but they are very small, they're very ineffective.
你在地方选举中没有投票权。你可能没有工作。你觉得这个体制对你不利，而且过去40年一直如此。你到哪里去寻找希望？圣母玛利亚。是的，你可能确实会向圣母玛利亚祈祷，完全正确。你可能会寄希望于北爱尔兰民族主义党，但他们非常小，非常无效。
I mean, in 1962 and 1965, in the Stormont Parliament, they won nine out of 52 seats. I mean, they're barely even in opposition, really. And they are generally seen as a bit old-fashioned, very Catholic, very rural, not terribly effective. Kind of Devalera type. A little bit, yeah, but Devalera is a very wily and ruthless politician and they are not. Right.
我的意思是，在1962年和1965年，在斯托蒙特议会中，他们赢得了52个席位中的9个。我的意思是，他们几乎算不上反对派。而且他们通常被认为有点老派，非常天主教，非常乡村，不是特别有效。有点像德瓦莱拉（Devalera）那种类型。有点像，是的，但德瓦莱拉是一个非常狡猾和无情的政治家，而他们不是。对。
Then you have the IRA. Now, the unionist hardliners talk all the time about the IRA. You know, they're obsessed with the IRA. They say the IRA, you know, is always out there, which, I mean, to be fair, it kind of is. The IRA had rebuilt after the Second World War and it had launched a new guerrilla campaign along the border in 1956 called Operation Harvest. and this campaign had been a complete and utter disaster. Both Belfast and Dublin, in fact, Amon de Valera,
然后你有爱尔兰共和军（IRA）。现在，统一派强硬派一直在谈论爱尔兰共和军。你知道，他们对爱尔兰共和军着迷。他们说爱尔兰共和军总是潜伏在那里，说实话，这在某种程度上确实如此。爱尔兰共和军在二战后进行了重建，并于1956年在边境发起了一场新的游击战，称为“丰收行动”（Operation Harvest）。这场运动彻底失败了。贝尔法斯特和都柏林，事实上，埃蒙·德瓦莱拉（Amon de Valera），
reintroduced internment without trial. They interned loads of IRA people and they completely broke the back of the organisation. And so in 1962, the IRA had called off this campaign, they dumped their weapons and madly, a few years later, they sold a lot of their weapons to the Welsh. Oh, to the Free Wales Army. Great. So people thinking it's just about Ireland.
重新引入了未经审判的拘留。他们拘留了大量的爱尔兰共和军成员，彻底摧毁了该组织的骨干。所以到了1962年，爱尔兰共和军取消了这场运动，他们丢弃了武器，疯狂的是，几年后，他们把很多武器卖给了威尔士人。哦，卖给了“自由威尔士军”（Free Wales Army）。太棒了。所以人们以为这只是关于爱尔兰的事。
It's about Wales as well. There's actually too much Welsh history. So much Welsh history in the West of history. It just keeps going. I know. They're everywhere. It's unbelievable. Right.
这也是关于威尔士的事。实际上有太多的威尔士历史。历史的西边有太多的威尔士历史。它一直在继续。我知道。他们无处不在。这简直令人难以置信。对。
So the IRA gets a new chief of staff who's from Dublin called Catholic Goulding. And Goulding says, listen, we have been wasting our time here. This has been a terrible mistake. And you said later, the notion that the IRA was going to rise up someday in Free Ireland and get rid of the British was a ridiculous pipe dream. I mean, that's a hell of a thing for the guy running the IRA to say in the early 60s. And this bloke Goulding, he's actually very close to some Marxist academics and to people from the British Communist Party.
所以爱尔兰共和军迎来了一位来自都柏林的新参谋长，名叫凯瑟琳·古尔丁（Cathal Goulding）。古尔丁说，听着，我们在这里浪费时间了。这是一个可怕的错误。你后来也说过，爱尔兰共和军有一天会在自由爱尔兰起义并赶走英国人的想法是一个荒谬的白日梦。我的意思是，对于一个在60年代初领导爱尔兰共和军的人来说，这真是一句惊人的话。而这个叫古尔丁的家伙，他实际上与一些马克思主义学者和英国共产党的人非常亲近。
And they persuade him the IRA's future lies in socialist activism. So he's listening to the British. He's listened to British academics, I know, which is mad. Never listened to a British academic. Instead of like blowing up post offices and stuff, why don't we work to build a non-sectarian workers' alliance that will fight both imperialism and capitalism? And the people who are running the IRA in the 60s say, yeah, actually, brilliant, let's do that. Because of course that goes with the momentum of the 60s, right? It feels right. Yeah, of course. So do they start going to conferences in goldsmiths?
他们说服他，爱尔兰共和军的未来在于社会主义激进主义。所以他在听英国人的话。他在听英国学者的建议，我知道，这太疯狂了。永远不要听英国学者的建议。与其炸毁邮局之类的，为什么我们不努力建立一个非宗派的工人联盟，既反对帝国主义又反对资本主义呢？而在60年代运营爱尔兰共和军的人说，是的，实际上，太棒了，我们这样做吧。因为这当然符合60年代的势头，对吧？感觉是对的。是的，当然。所以他们开始去金史密斯学院（Goldsmiths）参加会议了吗？
They do. There's probably men with polo necks. They have a lot of seminars. There are a lot of. There's a lot of talking shops about smashing capitalism. They're massively into this. Now, if you're an older IRA veteran, you are not pleased about this at all. So a lot of older IRA men are culturally conservative Catholics. They are not Marxists. So Joe Cahill, who was an IRA veteran who had been jailed for killing a policeman in 1942. He said, the movement was being led off the true path of republicanism. Ultra left politics were taking over. Sooner or later, they would have to be a showdown. And he's right. And the will. be a showdown. I mean, people say that Sinn Féin are doing the same at the moment, that they're becoming Corbinist, really.
他们去了。那里可能有穿着高领毛衣的男人。他们有很多研讨会。有很多关于粉碎资本主义的空谈。他们非常热衷于此。现在，如果你是一个老派的爱尔兰共和军老兵，你对此一点也不高兴。所以很多老派的爱尔兰共和军成员是文化保守的天主教徒。他们不是马克思主义者。所以乔·卡希尔（Joe Cahill），一位因在1942年杀害一名警察而入狱的爱尔兰共和军老兵，他说，运动正在被带离共和主义的真正道路。极左政治正在接管。迟早会有一场摊牌。他是对的。而且确实会有一场摊牌。我的意思是，人们说新芬党（Sinn Féin）现在也在做同样的事情，他们真的变得像科尔宾（Corbynist）了。
Exactly, that they're sort of caught between, you know, the Catholic nationalism on the one hand and a slightly woolly Marxist internationalism. Yes, on the other. Now, we'll come back to this later in the series, but the point really is that they've gone very, very quiet. So a future member of the provisional IRA, Billy McKee's quote from him, I believe that it was dead, completely dead, and it was, except in the minds of myself and other old republic. So, to return to the original question, if you're a Catholic, where are you looking for help? There is an alternative, of course, you could look to Dublin. Now, in theory, the Republic of Ireland claims the whole island. Article 2 of the Irish Constitution, the national territory consists of the whole island of Ireland. And Irish politicians would always say if they're asked, well, our goal, of course, is unification of the entire island. in reality, since the 1920s, governments in Dublin have shown no interest in advancing this at all and done absolutely nothing about it.
完全正确，他们一方面被困在天主教民族主义中，另一方面被困在一种稍微模糊的马克思主义国际主义中。是的，另一方面。现在，我们稍后会在本系列中回到这一点，但重点是他们已经变得非常非常安静了。所以未来临时爱尔兰共和军的一名成员，比利·麦基（Billy McKee）引用他的话说，我相信它已经死了，彻底死了，除了在我自己和其他老共和党人的脑海中。所以，回到最初的问题，如果你是天主教徒，你在哪里寻找帮助？当然有另一种选择，你可以看向都柏林。现在，理论上，爱尔兰共和国声称拥有整个岛屿。《爱尔兰宪法》第2条规定，国家领土由爱尔兰全岛组成。如果被问及，爱尔兰政治家总是会说，嗯，我们的目标当然是整个岛屿的统一。实际上，自20世纪20年代以来，都柏林的政府对推进这一点毫无兴趣，也完全没有采取任何行动。
And again, this is something that will surprise, I think, a lot of listeners. Twice in the Second World War, the British said to the government in Dublin, we will give you a united Ireland if you abandon your neutrality and join the Allies. after Pearl Harbor in 1941, Winston Churchill sent an incredible telegram to Amon de Valera. Now is your chance, now or never, a nation once again. So the nation once again is a kind of Republican slogan. Churchill was using it. And Devala just completely ignored him.
而且，我认为这会让很多听众感到惊讶。在二战期间，英国人曾两次对都柏林政府说，如果你放弃中立并加入盟军，我们将给你一个统一的爱尔兰。1941年珍珠港事件后，温斯顿·丘吉尔（Winston Churchill）给埃蒙·德瓦莱拉发了一封令人难以置信的电报。现在是你的机会，机不可失，时不再来，国家再次统一。所以“国家再次统一”是一种共和主义口号。丘吉尔当时正在使用它。而德瓦莱拉完全无视了他。
Didn't want to abandon neutrality. And also, of course, if you are a politician in Dublin, you don't really want those one million Protestants who have a tendency to sign governance and join volunteer, groups to fight you. I mean, that's an issue right the way up to the present, really, isn't it? To the present, exactly, of course. So in 1959, Devalera, the great champion of Irish independence and Irish republicanism, retired as Taoiseach, and he became president of Ireland, kind of kicked upstairs, and he was succeeded by a man called Sean Lamas. I mean, it's unbelievable, he's called Le Mass. I know, I know. I mean, anything more calculated to
不想放弃中立。而且，当然，如果你是都柏林的政治家，你并不真的想要那一百万有倾向签署治理协议并加入志愿组织来对抗你的新教徒。我的意思是，这确实是一个一直持续到今天的问题，不是吗？直到今天，完全正确，当然。所以1959年，爱尔兰独立和爱尔兰共和主义的伟大捍卫者德瓦莱拉退休了，不再担任总理（Taoiseach），他成为了爱尔兰总统，算是被“提拔”了，接替他的是一个叫肖恩·勒马斯（Sean Lemass）的人。我的意思是，这令人难以置信，他叫勒马斯。我知道，我知道。我的意思是，还有什么比勒马斯更让佩斯利感到……
alami and Paisley than LaMas. We shall come to this. LaMass had fought in the Easter Rising and he'd also been in the IRA. But in private, Lamass said to people, come on. The island's going to be partitioned for a long time yet. There's no point in whinging about this. It's not going to change anytime soon. So Dublin's not really interested in the Catholics in Northern Ireland.
比勒马斯更让佩斯利感到……我们稍后会谈到这一点。勒马斯参加过复活节起义，也参加过爱尔兰共和军。但在私下里，勒马斯对人们说，得了吧。这个岛还要被分裂很长一段时间。抱怨这个没有意义。它不会很快改变。所以都柏林对北爱尔兰的天主教徒并不真正感兴趣。
And if they're not really interested, people who are even less interested are politicians in London. Now, there are some Labor MPs. There are always Labour MPs who campaign against discrimination against the Catholics. So this goes back to your point on how could this happen in Britain? Well, I kind of think, I mean, it's a massive block on the British state that it's allowing this to happen, I think. But the British state, first of all, it's running an empire for most of this period. So, I mean, it's not like there are other places where there are, you know, interesting local arrangements.
如果他们不感兴趣，那么伦敦的政治家就更不感兴趣了。现在，有一些工党议员。总有一些工党议员反对对天主教徒的歧视。所以这回到了你关于这怎么可能在英国发生的观点上。嗯，我有点认为，我的意思是，英国国家允许这种情况发生是一个巨大的污点，我想。但英国国家，首先，在这一时期的大部分时间里，它在运营一个帝国。所以，我的意思是，这并不是说没有其他地方有，你知道，有趣的当地安排。
But by the mid-60s. Yes, and people in the 60s start to say this. So you have a Labour backbench, what's it called, the campaign for democracy in Ulster, that kicks off in the mid-60s. You have newspapers, like the Times, the Sunday Times, the Guardian, drawing attention to this and saying it's kind of not right that these people don't get houses and they don't really get to vote in local elections and stuff like this. But here's why people don't get massively excited about it. ever since the 1920s, most British politicians have worked in the assumption of the Irish question which had dogged Britain for so long has been solved. It's done.
但到了60年代中期。是的，60年代的人们开始这么说。所以你有一个工党后座议员组织，叫什么来着，阿尔斯特民主运动（campaign for democracy in Ulster），它在60年代中期开始。你有像《泰晤士报》、《星期日泰晤士报》、《卫报》这样的报纸，引起人们对这一点的关注，并说这些人得不到房子，在地方选举中也无法真正投票，这有点不对劲。但这就是为什么人们对此并不感到非常兴奋的原因：自20世纪20年代以来，大多数英国政治家都认为困扰英国已久的爱尔兰问题已经解决了。它完成了。
It's finished. The people in the North, we've fixed it because they've got their own parliament. We'll just let them get on with it. It's not perfect. But we absolutely don't want to interfere because they have a tendency to start arming themselves and we don't want to stir them up again. What has happened in Britain is that Northern Ireland has vanished from the national consciousness. It virtually never appears in the newspapers.
它结束了。北方的人们，我们已经解决了，因为他们有自己的议会。我们让他们自己处理吧。这并不完美。但我们绝对不想干涉，因为他们有武装自己的倾向，我们不想再次煽动他们。在英国发生的事情是，北爱尔兰已经从民族意识中消失了。它几乎从未出现在报纸上。
It's never mentioned in TV bulletins, news bulletins. Most people never think about it at all. I mentioned Jim Callahan before. Jim Callahan, grandson of Irish immigrant. And I quote, most members of Parliament knew less about it than we knew about our distant colonies on the far side of the earth.
它从未在电视新闻简报中被提及。大多数人根本从不考虑它。我之前提到过吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callahan）。吉姆·卡拉汉，爱尔兰移民的孙子。我引用他的话，大多数国会议员对它的了解比我们对地球另一端遥远殖民地的了解还要少。
And I think that's true. There's loads in British newspapers about Cyprus in the 1950s. There's loads about Kenya. There's loads about Malaysia. there's virtually nothing about Northern Ireland. And actually, people think, well, what's the point? Nothing's ever going to change.
我认为这是真的。英国报纸上有很多关于1950年代塞浦路斯的内容。有很多关于肯尼亚的内容。有很多关于马来西亚的内容。几乎没有关于北爱尔兰的内容。实际上，人们想，嗯，有什么意义呢？什么都不会改变。
The unionists hold every single Westminster seat. The nationalist is totally irrelevant. The IRA have been beaten. And frankly, most people in Northern Ireland, they might be Protestant, they might be Catholic, but this is the 60s. It's the affluent society. They're more interested in buying a new TV or a new washing machine than they are about refighting the kind of the battles of the past.
统一派占据了每一个威斯敏斯特席位。民族主义者完全无关紧要。爱尔兰共和军已经被击败了。坦率地说，北爱尔兰的大多数人，他们可能是新教徒，也可能是天主教徒，但这是60年代。这是一个富裕的社会。他们对购买新电视或新洗衣机比对重打过去的战争更感兴趣。
So this is the Sandbrook perspective. Well, that would be the Sanbrough, perspective and I would be wrong all about washing machines. In this instance, my washing machine eccentric view of history would be absolutely discredited because everybody thinks life is going to go on, everything is going to be the same forever and ever and they are wrong because things are about to change very dramatically indeed. And Dominic, we will find out how and why after a break. There have been disappointments. frustrations, but progress has been so marked that there is no excuse for pessimism about the future.
所以这就是桑布鲁克（Sandbrook）的视角。嗯，那将是桑布鲁克的视角，而我关于洗衣机的观点将是完全错误的。在这种情况下，我那种关于洗衣机的古怪历史观将被彻底否定，因为每个人都认为生活会继续下去，一切都会永远保持不变，但他们错了，因为事情即将发生非常剧烈的变化。多米尼克，我们将在休息后找出原因和方式。虽然有失望，有挫折，但进步是如此显著，以至于没有理由对未来感到悲观。
The six counties, unlike their neighbours across the border, belong to the British welfare state. They share too, as they richly deserve, many of the fruits of the affluent society. The processes of modernisation have been carried far, and they are not halted. On the contrary, they are on the march. So welcome back to the rest of history and that ringingly optimistic, groovy 60s perspective was in the Times
这六个郡，与边境那边的邻居不同，属于英国福利国家。他们也分享了，正如他们理应得到的那样，富裕社会的许多成果。现代化的进程已经走得很远，而且没有停止。相反，它们正在前进。欢迎回到历史的其余部分，那种响亮而乐观、时髦的60年代视角出现在《泰晤士报》上。
on the 12th of April, in 1965, looking ahead to a bright new future for Northern Ireland. Great to see the Times with its finger on the pulse. Always. The paper for top people.
1965年4月12日，展望北爱尔兰光明的未来。很高兴看到《泰晤士报》紧跟时代脉搏。一直如此。顶级人士的报纸。
And I suppose that top people sitting in their gentleman's clubs reading those words, it would have seen beyond the bounds of possibility to them, that within a few years, there would be bombs going off everywhere in the streets of Belfast and Derry, British soldiers patrolling those streets, hundreds of people being killed every year, and the carnage of it all spreading to the British mainland. Yeah.
我想，那些坐在绅士俱乐部里读着这些话的顶级人士，在他们看来，几年之内，贝尔法斯特和德里的街道上到处都会发生爆炸，英国士兵在街上巡逻，每年有数百人被杀，而这一切的杀戮蔓延到英国本土，这在他们看来是不可能的。是的。
So what goes wrong? I mean, what happens? What happens? But big question. That's what the series is all about, Tom. So let's start on the 25th of March, 1963. So this is the day that Captain Terence O'Neill becomes the fourth Prime Minister of Northern Ireland. So in 1963, Harold McMillan is Prime Minister in Britain.
那么出了什么问题？我的意思是，发生了什么？发生了什么？这是一个大问题。这就是本系列节目的全部内容，汤姆。所以让我们从1963年3月25日开始。这是特伦斯·奥尼尔（Terence O'Neill）上尉成为北爱尔兰第四任总理的日子。所以1963年，哈罗德·麦克米伦（Harold McMillan）是英国首相。
The Beatles are about to launch their greatest salt on the charts. You know, they're only months away from going to America. The swinging 60s are kind of poised to happen, all of this. And Northern Ireland is going to get an exciting dynamic, modernising new Prime Minister. And this is Captain O'Neill. So Captain O'Neill is almost 50 years old. His father was an Ulster Unionist. His father was the first MP to be killed in the First World War.
披头士乐队即将发起他们对排行榜的最大冲击。你知道，他们离去美国只有几个月的时间了。摇摆的60年代即将到来，所有这些。而北爱尔兰将迎来一位令人兴奋、充满活力、现代化的新总理。这就是奥尼尔上尉。所以奥尼尔上尉快50岁了。他的父亲是阿尔斯特统一党人。他的父亲是第一次世界大战中阵亡的第一位议员。
He was born in London, brought up in London. He went to Eton. He spent his summers in Northern Ireland. He served in a tank brigade in the Second World War. Two of his brothers were killed in the war, but he wasn't. And afterwards he became an Ulster Unionist MP as his father had before him. And then he rose to become Northern Ireland's Minister of Finance. And then in 63, the party grantees, they chose him to succeed the elderly Lord Brookborough as prime minister.
他在伦敦出生，在伦敦长大。他去了伊顿公学。他在北爱尔兰度过夏天。他在二战中服役于坦克旅。他的两个兄弟在战争中阵亡，但他没有。后来他像他父亲一样成为了阿尔斯特统一党议员。然后他升任北爱尔兰财政部长。然后在63年，党内大佬们选择了让他接替年迈的布鲁克伯勒勋爵（Lord Brookborough）担任总理。
Now, O'Neill knows that when he takes the reins, he's facing a big challenge. But in his mind, that challenge is primarily economic. So in our previous series, when we talked about Ireland or indeed when we did the Titanic, we talked about how Belfast was different from other cities in Ireland. It's made a brick, you know, not stone. It feels like a northern English city transplanted across the Irish Sea. It's an industrial powerhouse. It makes all its linen in the mills and it's got its shipyards and it's got chimneys and smoke and the sand of hammers and all of that kind of thing.
现在，奥尼尔知道当他掌权时，他面临着巨大的挑战。但在他看来，这个挑战主要是经济上的。所以在我们之前的系列节目中，当我们谈论爱尔兰或者我们做泰坦尼克号时，我们谈到了贝尔法斯特与爱尔兰其他城市有何不同。它是用砖砌成的，你知道，不是石头。它感觉就像一个移植到爱尔兰海对岸的英格兰北部城市。它是一个工业强国。它在工厂里生产所有的亚麻，它有造船厂，有烟囱和烟雾，有锤子的声音，所有这些东西。
And of course, that's brilliant if you're in 1900. But if you're in 1963, this is the kind of place that's going to be left behind by the harsh winds of global competition. Even in the 50s, jobs in textiles and shipbuilding had been shrinking dramatically. an unemployment was going up. And unemployment was already higher than in the rest of Britain and earnings lower than the rest of Britain. So if you're an Ulster Unionist, this has political consequences. Because you look at the electoral map
当然，如果你在1900年，那太棒了。但如果你在1963年，这就是那种会被全球竞争的严酷风暴抛在后面的地方。即使在50年代，纺织和造船业的工作岗位也在急剧萎缩。失业率正在上升。失业率已经高于英国其他地区，收入也低于英国其他地区。所以如果你是一个阿尔斯特统一党人，这会产生政治后果。因为你看着选举地图，
and there's a slow, steady advance of a Northern Irish Labour Party that's appealing to kind of working class people and saying, you know, times are tough, we're going to better represent you than the old stuck-up unionist grantees. And so for a terrorist, Prince O'Neill, he thinks, well, my priority is to revive the Northern Irish economy by getting new investment. And I'm going to look abroad for that investment. I'm going to get
北爱尔兰工党正在缓慢而稳定地前进，它吸引了工人阶级，并说，你知道，时代艰难，我们会比那些老派、傲慢的统一党大佬更好地代表你们。所以对于特伦斯·奥尼尔来说，他认为，嗯，我的首要任务是通过获得新的投资来振兴北爱尔兰经济。我要去国外寻找投资。我要获得
multinational companies, Michelin, Ford, ICI, these big names, they'll come to Northern Ireland because their labour costs are cheaper. But there are two issues with this. Issue number one. Most of this happens in Belfast or the east of the country, the places that are more urbanised and have better transport links with the island of Great Britain. But in the West, which is more heavily Catholic, where unemployment is already higher, these companies don't want to invest there. So these places feel like they're being left behind. And people there say, well, Terrence O'Neill talks a good game, but he only cares about the Protestants in the East, doesn't care about us at all. But then the other thing, the sort of more counterintuitive thing about all this new
跨国公司，米其林、福特、ICI，这些大牌，他们会来到北爱尔兰，因为他们的劳动力成本更便宜。但这里有两个问题。第一个问题。这种情况大部分发生在贝尔法斯特或该国的东部，那些更城市化、与大不列颠岛交通联系更好的地方。但在西部，天主教徒更多，失业率已经更高，这些公司不想在那里投资。所以这些地方感觉自己被抛在了后面。人们说，嗯，特伦斯·奥尼尔说得好听，但他只关心东部的新教徒，根本不关心我们。但还有另一件事，关于所有这些新投资的更反直觉的事情，
investment, it's very disruptive to Northern Ireland's existing arrangements. Because If you're, you know, Ford or Michelin or something, and you arrive, you're the sort of, you're like people from madmen or something. You know, you've got a kind of sharp suit. You like a graph and a table and all that stuff. You've got all these time and motion studies. And then people say to you, well, you know, we'll be wearing our bowler hats and we're going on a big march. And obviously we can't have any Catholics. You stare at them in stupefaction and disbelief and you say, well, that's not, you know, the Ford motor company does not operate that way or whatever. Get with it. Exactly. And so there's a degree of tension between the newcomers, you know, the new investment, the new companies, and then the people who basically are like, come on, we spend our evenings always at the Orange Lodge and we sing our sex songs about the glorious revolution. Now, this would not have been insuperable for a sort of populist politician for a more skillful communicator to handle. But Terence O'Neill is not that man. As we said, he's an old Etonian, he's married to an English woman, and he has an English accent because he's been brought up in London. And so, although he goes down quite well with the kind of country landowners, because he's very posh, the poorer, more conservative, working-class Protestants, they see him as soft and as stuck up and as somebody who's totally oblivious to their concerns. So I already mentioned David Trimble, leader of the Ulster Unionist in the 1990s. He said of Terrence O'Neill,
它对北爱尔兰现有的安排非常具有破坏性。因为如果你是福特或米其林之类的公司，当你到达时，你就像《广告狂人》（Madmen）里的人一样。你知道，你穿着考究的西装。你喜欢图表和表格之类的东西。你有很多时间与动作研究。然后人们对你说，嗯，你知道，我们会戴着圆顶礼帽，我们要去参加一场大游行。显然我们不能有任何天主教徒。你目瞪口呆，难以置信地看着他们，你说，嗯，那不是，你知道，福特汽车公司不是那样运作的，或者其他什么。跟上时代吧。完全正确。所以新来者、新投资、新公司与那些基本上说“得了吧，我们晚上总是在奥兰治分会，我们唱关于光荣革命的性歌”的人之间存在一定程度的紧张关系。现在，对于一个民粹主义政治家或一个更熟练的沟通者来说，这并非不可克服。但特伦斯·奥尼尔不是那样的人。正如我们所说，他是一个老伊顿生，娶了一个英国妻子，而且因为他在伦敦长大，他有英国口音。所以，尽管他在乡村地主中很受欢迎，因为他非常时髦，但那些更贫穷、更保守的工人阶级新教徒认为他软弱、傲慢，是一个完全无视他们担忧的人。所以我已经提到了大卫·特林布尔，90年代的阿尔斯特统一党领袖。他这样评价特伦斯·奥尼尔：
he never spoke or behaved as if he was one of us, which is, I think, true. He has a slight Look, of the former editor of The Daily Telegraph. Yeah. Charles Moore. And like Charles Moore, Charles Moore is the head of the rectory society or something. He loves an old rectory. Yes. And I believe Terrence O'Neill lived in a regency rectory.
他说话或行为方式从来不像我们中的一员，我认为这是真的。他有一点《每日电讯报》前主编的样子。是的。查尔斯·摩尔（Charles Moore）。像查尔斯·摩尔一样，查尔斯·摩尔是教区协会的负责人之类的。他喜欢老教区。是的。我相信特伦斯·奥尼尔住在一个摄政时期的教区住宅里。
And that's a very bad sign under person. Is it not? Never trust a man who owns a regency rectory. No, they're terrible people. So Terence O'Neil also lacks natural political skills. He's very luff. He's very shy. He's cold.
这在一个人身上是一个非常糟糕的迹象。不是吗？永远不要相信一个拥有摄政时期教区住宅的人。不，他们是可怕的人。所以特伦斯·奥尼尔也缺乏天生的政治技巧。他非常冷漠。他非常害羞。他很冷淡。
One of his own minister said he was distant and uninspiring. not have felt like dying in a ditch for him. And I don't think that's ideal. You know, it's not unfamiliar. I mean, we've had prime ministers like that. In fact, quite recently, we've had a couple of prime ministers like that. But it's not the ideal type for this moment. So actually, after a couple of years, more conservative Protestants are beginning to wonder whether O'Neill is really the man for the job after all. And he keeps doing things that worry them. So, for example, in 1965, he became the first Prime Minister of Northern Ireland to welcome the Taoiseach, the Prime Minister of the Republic of Ireland.
他的一位部长说他疏远且缺乏灵感。不会让人觉得想为他去死。我不认为那是理想的。你知道，这并不陌生。我的意思是，我们有过那样的首相。事实上，最近我们就有几个那样的首相。但这并不是那个时刻的理想类型。所以实际上，几年后，更保守的新教徒开始怀疑奥尼尔是否真的是这份工作的人选。他一直在做让他们担心的事情。例如，1965年，他成为第一位欢迎爱尔兰共和国总理（Taoiseach）的北爱尔兰总理。
This is Sean LaMass. Now, Terence O'Neill said, well, it's good to have this boat LaMass here because we want to build bridges with our neighbours, we want to build bridges with the Republic. And one of his critics, who was the Presbyterian minister, said, A bridge and a traitor are very much alike, for they both go over to the other side. And the name of the man who said this was the man we heard in that introduction. Oh, Ian Paisley. The Reverend Ian Paisley.
这就是肖恩·勒马斯。现在，特伦斯·奥尼尔说，嗯，让勒马斯来这里很好，因为我们想与邻居建立桥梁，我们想与共和国建立桥梁。而他的批评者之一，那位长老会牧师说，桥梁和叛徒非常相似，因为他们都去了另一边。而说这话的人的名字就是我们在介绍中听到的那个人。哦，伊恩·佩斯利。伊恩·佩斯利牧师。
So he's back in the show. Great. Great to have him back. So Paisley is really an incredible character. I did worry that he would slightly take over this episode. And maybe that would be no bad thing. He is this colossal figure in the life of Northern Ireland. He goes from the most sort of strident demagoguery to power sharing in the 19th.
所以他又回到了节目中。太棒了。很高兴他回来了。所以佩斯利确实是一个不可思议的人物。我确实担心他会稍微接管这一集。也许那也不是坏事。他是北爱尔兰生活中这个巨大的形象。他从最尖锐的煽动者变成了90年代和2000年代的权力分享者，这作为一个轨迹看起来简直疯了。而且像这个故事中的每个人一样，他深受历史的影响。所以他1926年出生在阿马（Armara）。他的父亲是浸信会牧师。他的父亲曾在爱德华·卡森（Sir Edward Carson）爵士的志愿军中服役。而伊恩·佩斯利本人成为了一名浸信会牧师，他在16岁时发表了第一次布道。哇。他是一个大块头。他有六英尺四英寸左右。你知道吗？他戴着牧师领看起来很棒。这真的很适合他。我认为当牧师领戴在瘦削的脖子上时，看起来有点虚弱。但对他来说，他看起来像一个戴着项圈的凯尔特战士。我的意思是，他可能不喜欢那个比较，实际上。是的，他看起来可能像一个撒克逊
90s and 2000s, which just seems absolutely bonkers as a trajectory. And like everyone else in this story, he is profoundly shaped by history. So he's born in Armara in 1926. His father was a Baptist minister. His father had served in Sir Edward Carson's volunteers. And Ian Paisley himself becomes a Baptist minister and he preached his first sermon when he was 16. Wow. He's a massive bloke. He's like six foot four or something. Do you know what? He looks brilliant in a dog collar. It really suits him. I think dog collars when they're around a scorny neck, look a bit a bit weedy. But with him, he looks like a Celtic warrior with a talk. I mean, he probably wouldn't like that comparison, actually. Yeah, he could look like a Saxon
战士，戴着项圈，也许。他可能会接受那个。我不知道。或者苏格兰战士，我想。所以这是这种煽动性的、原教旨主义的风格。1951年，他建立了自己的一种加尔文主义教会，北爱尔兰自由长老会。他相信圣经的字面真理。他认为阿尔斯特的既定教会，在大多数观察家看来是相当强硬的保守派教会，但他认为他们是软弱的、罗马化的卖国贼。当然有一个明显的平行，
warrior with the talk, maybe. He might take that. I don't know. Or Scottish, Scottish warrior, I suppose. So it's this firebrand, fundamentalist style. In 1951, he set up his own kind of Calvinist church, the Free Presbyterian Church of Ulster. He believes in the literal truth of the Bible. He thinks the established churches of Ulster, which strike most observers as quite hard-line conservative churches, but he thinks they are weak, soft, romish sellouts. There's an obvious parallel, of course,
与美国南部的福音派传教士，在他生命的后期，他确实与南卡罗来纳州的鲍勃·琼斯大学（Bob Jones University）建立了非常牢固的联系。我知道。鲍勃·琼斯大学。你知道鲍勃·琼斯大学吗？不。你不知道。鲍勃·琼斯大学是一件大事，因为鲍勃·琼斯大学是一所反天主教、超新教的大学，福音派。我不记得它是什么时候建立的，但乔治·杜普利·布什（George Dupily Bush）在2000年竞选共和党提名时去那里发表了演讲。
with Southern evangelical preachers in the United States, and later in his life, he does forge very strong links with Bob Jones University in South Carolina. I know. Bob Jones University. Are you aware of Bob Jones University? No. You're not. Bob Jones University is a big deal because Bob Jones University was anti-Catholic, ultra-protestant university, evangelical. I can't remember when it was set up, but George Dupily Bush went and gave a speech there in 2000 when he was campaigning for the Republican nomination.
它是被一个叫鲍勃·琼斯的人建立的吗？还是他们只是……让我们想一个有趣的名字。鲍勃·琼斯，你嘲笑鲍勃·琼斯，你嘲笑鲍勃·琼斯大学，你这样做是愚蠢的。它有3000名学生。它有2000万美元的捐赠基金。现任校长是鲍勃·琼斯三世。好吧，我收回刚才的话。我向鲍勃·琼斯道歉。所以无论如何，伊恩·佩斯利与鲍勃·琼斯大学建立了联系。所以有一种，有很多南方福音派人士喜欢伊恩·佩斯利。他的名片，很像鲍勃·琼斯的那张，实际上，是绝对火热的、福音派的、老式的反天主教主义。如果人们喜欢反天主教的言论，
Was it set up by a guy called Bob James? Or did they just... Let's think of a funny name. Bob Jones, you laugh at Bob Jones, you laugh at Bob Jones's University and you're foolish to do so. It has 3,000 students. It has an endowment to $20 million. And the current Chancellor, Bob Jones III. Well, I take it all back. I apologize to Bob Jones. So anyway, Ian Paisley forged links at Bob Jones University. And so there's a sort of, there are lots of Southern evangelicals who love Ian Paisley. His calling card, rather like that of Bob Jones, actually, is absolutely red-hot, evangelical. old-fashioned anti-Catholicism. And if people enjoy anti-Catholic rhetoric,
这个播客就是它的地方。我应该做吗？你做吗？是的，我认为你应该做，因为你模仿那个声音。通过教皇制度，魔鬼堵住了通往我们遗产的道路。祭司权、迷信和民粹主义，伴随着所有随之而来的谋杀、盗窃、不道德、淫欲和乱伦的声音。
this podcast is the place for it. Should I do it? Do you do it? Yeah, I think you should do it because you do the voice. Through popery, the devil has shut up the way to our inheritance. Priestcraft, superstition, and populism, with all their attendant voices of murder, theft, immorality, lust, and incest.
阻挡了通往福音自由之地的道路。那是，那是，是的，那是，那是，我的意思是，这是一种观点。现在，人们可能对他说祭司权及其随之而来的谋杀之类的声音感到惊讶，但也包括淫欲和乱伦。他对此非常字面化，不是吗？是的，现在，在伊恩·佩斯利的布道中有很多关于淫欲和乱伦的谈论。
have blocked the way to the land of gospel liberty. That's, that's, yeah, that's, that's good. That's, that is, I mean, it's a view. Now, people may have raised their eyebrows there about the, he's talking about priestcraft and its attendant voices of murder and whatnot, but also lust and incest. He takes it very literally, doesn't he? Yeah, now, there's a lot of talk of lust and incest in Ian Paiseser Merns.
他喜欢所有这些。所以在他第一次祈祷会上，他过去常常像玩杰克盒子一样，让一个修女跳出来。他会说，这个修女从天主教修道院逃了出来。她是僧侣和其他修女性骚扰的受害者。我已经救了她，她看到了光明，她要告诉我们所有关于天主教的邪恶。他有自己的报纸，《新教电报》（Protestant Telegraph），它的一些头条新闻。祭司谋杀案曝光。儿童受折磨，僧侣被揭露为虐待狂。
He loves all this. So in his first prayer meetings, he used to, like sort of jack in the box, a nun would pop up. And he would say, this nun has escaped from a Catholic convent. And she was the victim of sexual overtures from monks and other nuns. And I have rescued her and she has seen the light that she's going to tell us all about the evils of Catholicism. He had his own newspaper, the Protestant Telegraph, some of its headlines. Priestly murders exposed. children tortured, monks turned out as sadists.
他非常喜欢这一切。所以在他最初的祈祷会上，他就像玩弹簧玩偶一样，让一个修女突然跳出来。他会说，这个修女是从天主教修道院逃出来的。她是僧侣和其他修女性骚扰的受害者。我已经救了她，她已经看清了真相，她要告诉我们所有关于天主教的罪恶。他有自己的报纸《新教电讯报》，其中一些标题是：揭露神职人员谋杀案、儿童受虐待、僧侣变成虐待狂。
Or probably my favorite thing that he said, when the moderator of the Church of Scotland made a cordial visit to the Pope, the headline in the Protestant Telegraph was, The Church of Scotland, drunk with the wine of the fornication with the Roman whore. And of course it's easy for us to mock, and it's very easy, and that's what we have been doing. But in Northern Ireland, where religious identity is so important,
或者可能是我最喜欢他所说的一句话，当苏格兰教会的主持人对教皇进行亲切访问时，《新教电讯报》的头条新闻是：“苏格兰教会，沉醉于与罗马妓女淫乱的酒中。”当然，我们很容易嘲笑，这非常容易，这也是我们一直在做的事情。但在宗教身份如此重要的北爱尔兰，
this finds a ready audience. He's a brilliant, brilliant speaker. I mean, that is the thing, isn't he? Yeah. There is a power to those tones. Toast there is. He's speaking with the timbre of John Fox and there's a kind of magnificent rhetorical role to it. But you know who would agree with you?
这很容易找到受众。他是一位非常、非常出色的演说家。我的意思是，这就是重点，不是吗？是的。那些语调有一种力量。确实如此。他说话时带着约翰·福克斯的音色，有一种宏伟的修辞作用。但你知道谁会同意你的观点吗？
Somebody very unexpected. The actor Liam Neeson, I will find you and I will kill you. You know, that guy. Yeah, he was an early impression, right? Very early impression. he was born from a Catholic family who's from County Antrim, but he was inspired by Ian Paisley
一个非常出人意料的人。演员连姆·尼森，“我会找到你，我会杀了你。”你知道，那个家伙。是的，他早年就对他有印象，对吧？非常早期的印象。他出生在一个来自安特里姆郡的天主教家庭，但他受到了伊恩·佩斯利的启发
to become an actor. He would go to see Ian Pace at his gospel hall and he said afterwards, you could see this extraordinary performance, the charisma that he had. It was electrifying. And loads of people talk about this. So a man will be talking about it a little bit later,
而成为了一名演员。他会去伊恩·佩斯利的福音堂看他，事后他说，你可以看到这种非凡的表演，他所拥有的魅力。这令人振奋。很多人都在谈论这一点。所以稍后会有一个人谈论这件事，
one of Paceous protégé's a guy called Noel Doherty. He was a teenage fundamentalist, he became a printer, and then he became a loyalist paramilitary. He said, I was spellbound by his oratory. I felt this is a man that is doing the Lord's work and I'm going to do it with him. I saw him as a great Ulsterman and a second Carson, again harking back to the history of the early 1910s. Now, in 60s Britain, people laughed at Ian Paisley and they said he's bonkers, he's a clown, he's a freak, he's a relic or whatever. But actually, we have done so many people like this on this show, different time periods.
佩斯利的门徒之一，一个叫诺埃尔·多尔蒂的人。他曾是一名十几岁的原教旨主义者，后来成为了一名印刷工，然后成为了一名效忠派准军事人员。他说：“我被他的演说迷住了。我觉得这是一个正在做上帝工作的人，我要和他一起做。我把他看作一位伟大的阿尔斯特人，第二个卡森，”再次回溯到1910年代初的历史。现在，在60年代的英国，人们嘲笑伊恩·佩斯利，说他是个疯子，是个小丑，是个怪胎，是个遗迹什么的。但实际上，我们在节目中已经讲过很多这样的人，在不同的时期。
You know, sav on a roller, the Ayatollah Khomeini. Imposing, charismatic, striking, rhetorically brilliant speakers who have a gift for giving these electrifying addresses that channel the anxieties of their listeners. Well, I mean, it might sound shocking, but Martin Luther King on the progressive side. Yeah, brilliant speaker. I mean, again, using the potency of biblical rhetoric. And like a lot of these people, Khomeini is a good example. you know, always dresses the same way. Ian Paisley has a costume.
你知道，萨文·阿·罗勒，阿亚图拉·霍梅尼。威严、有魅力、引人注目、修辞上极其出色的演说家，他们有一种天赋，能发表那些引导听众焦虑的振奋人心的演讲。嗯，我的意思是，这听起来可能很令人震惊，但马丁·路德·金在进步派那边。是的，出色的演说家。我的意思是，再次强调，利用了圣经修辞的力量。而且像这些人中的许多人一样，霍梅尼就是一个很好的例子。你知道，总是穿同样的衣服。伊恩·佩斯利有一套戏服。
He's got a flare for publicity. So in this period, he always wears a black suit. He wears his white clerical collar, which you liken to a talk. And he had something that he doesn't really persist with NATO Life, which is he has this trademark raincoat. Because the 60s is a great age for a coat. This is a Gannex rain tape. I don't think it's Gannex, like Harold Wilson's.
他有宣传的天赋。所以在这个时期，他总是穿着黑色西装。他戴着白色的牧师领，你把它比作一种谈话。而且他有一些在北约生活中并没有真正坚持的东西，那就是他有这件标志性的雨衣。因为60年代是一个穿大衣的好时代。这是一件Gannex雨衣。我不认为它是Gannex，像哈罗德·威尔逊的那种。
It's more old-fashioned than that. It's this huge, because he's so massive. It's this massive, like white belt. coat that he always wears. He does sometimes wear orange man's sash, doesn't he? Oh yeah, he'll wear an orange sash when the time calls for it. And he's very good at publicity stunts that are very attractive to the newspapers and they look good on TV.
它比那更老式。它是这件巨大的，因为他太庞大了。这是一件巨大的，像白腰带一样的大衣，他总是穿着。他有时确实会戴橙色兄弟会的饰带，不是吗？哦，是的，当需要的时候，他会戴上一条橙色饰带。而且他非常擅长那些对报纸非常有吸引力且在电视上看起来不错的宣传噱头。
So to give you some of his stunts, he first really came to public attention in 1956. He rescued a 15-year-old Catholic girl called Morrill Lions. More Allian's had decided she wanted to join Ian Pais' church and her parents forbade it. So he and his reporters smuggled her to Scotland. You know, this was a massive story. I mean, they basically kidnapped this teenager. And he was absolutely unrepentant. He called a rally. Whenever he's in trouble, he calls a rally in the Ulster Hall in Belfast. And he said, they're saying, I'm going to have to go to prison. I would be proud to do time for Protestant liberty. Like he always says this kind of thing. That was actually Richard Nixon's voice.
所以举几个他的噱头，他第一次真正引起公众注意是在1956年。他救了一个叫莫里尔·莱昂斯的15岁天主教女孩。莫里尔·莱昂斯决定她想加入伊恩·佩斯利的教会，但她的父母禁止了。所以他和他的记者们把她偷运到了苏格兰。你知道，这是一个巨大的新闻。我的意思是，他们基本上绑架了这个少年。而且他完全不知悔改。他召集了一次集会。每当他遇到麻烦时，他就会在贝尔法斯特的阿尔斯特大厅召集集会。他说：“他们说，我将不得不去坐牢。我会为新教的自由而坐牢感到自豪。”就像他总是说这种话一样。那实际上是理查德·尼克松的声音。
Two years later, the queen, he condemns, I mean, he loves putting the boot into the British when they let the side down. The queen mother and Princess Margaret made a courtesy call to Pope John the 23rd. He said of them, they've been committing spiritual fornication and adultery with the Antichrist. I mean, accusing the Queen mother of fornication and adultery is strong stuff, I think, especially with the Antichrist. I mean, it would get you in the papers. wouldn't it? It would. Saying stuff like that.
两年后，女王，他谴责，我的意思是，他喜欢在英国人让局面失望时给他们一脚。王太后和玛格丽特公主对教皇约翰二十三世进行了礼节性访问。他谈到她们时说：“她们一直在与敌基督进行精神上的淫乱和通奸。”我的意思是，指责王太后淫乱和通奸是很严重的事情，我想，尤其是与敌基督。我的意思是，这会让你上报纸，不是吗？会的。说这种话。
Or when the Pope died in 1963, Terrence O'Neill, a consulatory gesture, said we will lower the Union Jack as a mark of respect, because after all, one in three of our citizens is actually a Catholic. Paisley went absolutely berserk at this. He said, I can't stand the lying euloges now being paid to the Roman Antichrist by the Escarats of Ulster. He said, the good news, though, he said,
或者当教皇在1963年去世时，特伦斯·奥尼尔，一个安抚性的姿态，说我们将降下联合杰克旗作为尊重的标志，因为毕竟，我们三分之一的公民实际上是天主教徒。佩斯利对此完全狂暴了。他说：“我无法忍受阿尔斯特的走狗现在向罗马敌基督支付的虚伪悼词。”他说，不过好消息是，他说，
the Romish man of sin is now in hell. Well, that's something. Do you remember in the 80s he disrupted the European Parliament? Yeah, he did. There was lots about the Antichrist and the Hall of Babylon and stuff. He was an MEP at this point, wasn't he? Was he not? And the Pope, Pope John Paul II, came to address the European Parliament,
“罗马的罪人现在在地狱里。”嗯，那是一回事。你还记得在80年代他扰乱了欧洲议会吗？是的，他做了。有很多关于敌基督和巴比伦大厅之类的事情。他当时是欧洲议会议员，不是吗？他不是吗？而教皇，教皇约翰·保罗二世，来欧洲议会发表讲话，
and Ian Paisley started, that was bundled out of the hall, shouting, I denounce you as Antichrist. He had massive jowls by that point, and they would kind of wobble all over his chest. Yeah. Well, anyway, we come to the Westminster General Election of 1964, and this story, this really is the politics of Northern Ireland in microcosm. So we're in West Belfast, which is historically over the city's four seats, the most competitive, because it contains the heavily Catholic Falls Road, which you mentioned earlier. And one of the candidates was a guy called Liam McMillan, who was an IRA man.
伊恩·佩斯利开始，被从大厅里赶了出去，大喊：“我谴责你是敌基督。”他那时有巨大的下巴，它们会在他的胸前晃动。是的。好吧，无论如何，我们来到1964年的威斯敏斯特大选，这个故事，这真的是北爱尔兰政治的缩影。所以我们在西贝尔法斯特，历史上该市的四个席位中，这是竞争最激烈的，因为它包含了你之前提到的天主教徒众多的福尔斯路。其中一位候选人是一个叫利亚姆·麦克米兰的人，他是一个爱尔兰共和军成员。
He'd been active in the border campaign, and he is standing as an independent Republican. And in the window of his election office in the lower falls, he hangs this big Irish tricolour flag. Now, under the Stormont Flags and Emblems Act of 1954, the RUC are empowered to take down any flags that they think are likely to provoke a breach of the peace. And this legislation was aimed specifically at people flying the Irish flag. But the police aren't completely stupid. When people fly it in Catholic areas, they generally leave it alone. just let them get on with it if that's what they want to do. Paisley is horrified by this.
他曾活跃在边境运动中，他以独立共和党人的身份参选。在他的下福尔斯选举办公室的窗户里，他挂着这面巨大的爱尔兰三色旗。现在，根据1954年的《斯托蒙特旗帜和徽章法》，北爱尔兰皇家警察有权取下他们认为可能引发破坏和平的任何旗帜。而这项立法专门针对那些悬挂爱尔兰国旗的人。但警察并不完全愚蠢。当人们在天主教地区悬挂它时，他们通常会置之不理。如果那是他们想做的，就让他们继续吧。佩斯利对此感到震惊。
He calls a big rally and he says, I do not accept that any part of Ulster is Republican. I do not want to see the tricolor flying here. And under this pressure, the IUC decide fine, we'll take it down. So on the 28th of September, a group of heavily armed police constables smashed down the door of this bloke's office and they carry off the flag
他召集了一次大型集会，他说：“我不接受阿尔斯特的任何部分是共和派的。我不希望看到三色旗在这里飘扬。”在这种压力下，北爱尔兰皇家警察决定好吧，我们会把它取下来。所以9月28日，一群全副武装的警察砸开了这个家伙办公室的门，他们带走了旗帜，
through a crowd of 2,000 people who were sort of jeering at them and throwing stones at them and stuff. And this kicked off the worst rioting in Ulster since the 1930s. In some ways, you could say this is a possible departure point for the troubles. There are thousands of people throwing stones and petrol bombs, people set a trolley bus on fire, and it ends with hundreds of our UC men,
穿过一群2000人的队伍，他们在那儿嘲笑他们，向他们扔石头之类的。这引发了自1930年代以来阿尔斯特最严重的骚乱。在某种程度上，你可以说这是“动乱”的一个可能的出发点。有成千上万的人在扔石头和汽油弹，人们点燃了一辆无轨电车，最后有数百名北爱尔兰皇家警察，
armed with batons, supported by armored cars and water cannons, physically clearing the falls road. And 50 people end up in hospital, as well as 18, RUC constables. And there's also copycat rioting, or sort of tip-for-tat rioting, by the way, in Dublin. There's a crowd when they hear this that assemble outside the British embassy, and they have to be held back by the Irish police, and they're kind of throwing stones of them. And this is the first point, really, since the war, that the British papers almost
手持警棍，在装甲车和高压水枪的支持下，物理清除了福尔斯路。50人最终进了医院，还有18名北爱尔兰皇家警察。顺便说一句，都柏林也发生了模仿骚乱，或者说是以牙还牙的骚乱。当他们听到这个消息时，有一群人聚集在英国大使馆外，他们不得不被爱尔兰警察拦住，他们向他们扔石头。这是自战争以来，英国报纸几乎
noticed Northern Ireland. So the Times, there is a sickening familiarity about all of this, it says, let's hope we're not returning to the bitterness and savagery of the orange and green vendetta. But from Paisley's point of view, this has been very effective. It's got his name in the newspapers once again. He's made a stand. The Irish flag has come down. He is the champion of Protestant liberty, as he would call it.
注意到北爱尔兰的第一个点。所以《泰晤士报》说，这一切有一种令人作呕的熟悉感，让我们希望我们没有回到橙色和绿色仇杀的痛苦和野蛮中。但从佩斯利的观点来看，这非常有效。它再次让他的名字上了报纸。他表明了立场。爱尔兰国旗被降下了。他是新教自由的捍卫者，正如他所称的那样。
And two weeks later, when the unionist candidate Jim Kilfeeder wins West Belfast, he makes a point in his speech of thanking Ian Paisley for his support. So that sets the scene for two years in which Ian Paisley is becoming ever more strident in his attacks on what he sees as the soft, weak, English, untrustworthy, Terrence O'Neill. So the visit of Sean Lamass from Dublin. This is when Ian Pace is going around shouting, no mass, no Lamass. And then he gets an even better gift a year later. It's going to be the 50th anniversary of the Easter Rising.
两周后，当统一派候选人吉姆·基尔菲德赢得西贝尔法斯特时，他在演讲中特意感谢了伊恩·佩斯利的全力支持。这为接下来的两年奠定了基础，在这两年里，伊恩·佩斯利对他所认为的软弱、虚弱、英国人、不可信的特伦斯·奥尼尔的攻击变得越来越尖锐。所以肖恩·勒马斯从都柏林的访问。这就是伊恩·佩斯利到处大喊“不要弥撒，不要勒马斯”的时候。然后一年后他得到了一个更好的礼物。这将是复活节起义50周年。
And you said yourself, you know, on the Falls Road, there are all the murals to the stay of the Easter Rising. They make a big deal of it. Of course, 1916, if you're a unionist, it's the year of the Somme. So it's like a history war, I guess, being played out in the streets of Belfast. O'Neill says, fine, let the Catholics have a, if they want to have a march to celebrate the Easter rising 50 years on, of course we'll let them do it. You know, it will be mad not to it. It will just create great tension if we ban it.
你自己也说过，你知道，在福尔斯路上，到处都是关于复活节起义的壁画。他们对此大做文章。当然，1916年，如果你是统一派，那是索姆河战役的一年。所以这就像一场历史战争，我想，在贝尔法斯特的街道上上演。奥尼尔说：“好吧，让天主教徒有一个，如果他们想举行游行来庆祝复活节起义50周年，当然我们会让他们这样做。”你知道，不这样做会很疯狂。如果我们禁止它，只会造成巨大的紧张。
Paisley is horrified by this. He tells a rally that by allowing this nationalist march, O'Neill is supporting murder, treason, sedition. Our forefathers suffered from bullets and bombs and won, we will do the same. Ian Pacey loves very violent rhetoric. Then there's another confrontation, June 1966. This time he's attacking the mainstream churches. So the mainstream Presbyterian church are holding their annual assembly.
佩斯利对此感到震惊。他在集会上说，通过允许这次民族主义游行，奥尼尔是在支持谋杀、叛国、煽动叛乱。“我们的祖先遭受了子弹和炸弹的袭击并赢得了胜利，我们也会这样做。”伊恩·佩斯利喜欢非常暴力的修辞。然后是另一次对抗，1966年6月。这一次他是在攻击主流教会。所以主流长老会正在举行他们的年度大会。
Paisley decides to lead 1,500 supporters to attack them for their Romanizing tendencies, as he quotes it. basically you could never be hard enough on Catholicism, I think for the Reverend Ian Paisley. And he leads his supporters through this very Catholic area deliberately. They're attacked by local youths. And the melee ends with lots of stone throwing, fighting, people throwing bricks at the IUC, all of this kind of thing.
佩斯利决定带领1500名支持者去攻击他们，因为他们有他所引用的“罗马化倾向”。基本上，我认为对于伊恩·佩斯利牧师来说，你永远不可能对天主教足够强硬。他故意带领他的支持者穿过这个非常天主教的地区。他们遭到了当地年轻人的袭击。这场混战以大量的扔石头、打架、人们向北爱尔兰皇家警察扔砖头等事情结束。
The magistrates then order Paisley to sign a court order to keep the peace, a pledge to keep the peace. And he says, no, I'm not going to do that. and they sentenced him to three months in Crumlin Road prison, and that provoked yet more rioting, thousands of his supporters going on the rampage, chanting his name, people attacking Catholic-owned businesses, Catholic shops, and so on and so forth. At this point, Terrence O'Neill, the Prime Minister of Northern Ireland, says, okay, enough, I've lost patience. I'm banning all marches, Protestant or Catholic, for the next three months. The RUC have the power to shut down all meetings,
地方法官随后命令佩斯利签署一份法院命令以维持和平，一份维持和平的承诺。他说：“不，我不会那样做。”他们判处他三个月监禁在克拉姆林路监狱，这引发了更多的骚乱，成千上万的支持者横冲直撞，高呼他的名字，人们攻击天主教拥有的企业、天主教商店等等。此时，北爱尔兰总理特伦斯·奥尼尔说：“好吧，够了，我失去了耐心。我禁止未来三个月内所有的游行，无论是新教还是天主教的。”北爱尔兰皇家警察有权关闭所有会议，
with more than three people in. You know, no more of this. And he gives a very, very outspoken speech at Stormont. And he says, Paisley and his supporters call themselves loyalists. But to whom are they loyal? To the Queen, whose personal representatives they revile. To the United Kingdom in which their fellow citizens view their conduct with a mixture of ridicule and contempt.
超过三人的。你知道，不要再这样了。他在斯托蒙特发表了一次非常、非常直言不讳的演讲。他说：“佩斯利和他的支持者自称是效忠派。但他们效忠于谁？效忠于女王，他们辱骂女王的个人代表。效忠于联合王国，他们的同胞以嘲笑和蔑视的态度看待他们的行为。
To Protestantism, many of whose leaders they have personally abused. I mean, it's good stuff. But O'Neill all the time is losing momentum And it's Paisley who is attracting momentum And part of this is the sort of ratchet effect of sectarian rhetoric But it's also the economic context The fact that people feel anxious about the future The fact that Northern Ireland feels like it's a changing society
效忠于新教，他们亲自辱骂了许多新教领袖。”我的意思是，这很好。但奥尼尔一直在失去动力，而佩斯利却在吸引动力。这部分是因为宗派修辞的某种棘轮效应。但这也是经济背景。人们对未来感到焦虑的事实。北爱尔兰感觉像是一个正在变化的社会的事实。
And a lot of people don't like that All of these kinds of things And all the time Paisley is attracting more recruits for his church And for its political wing which was called Ulster Protestant Action. He had set this up twofold reasons, really. One, he'd said this will deter the IRA, but he also said,
很多人不喜欢那样。所有这些事情。而且佩斯利一直在为他的教会吸引更多的招募者。以及它的政治分支，被称为“阿尔斯特新教行动”。他建立这个有两个原因，真的。第一，他说这将威慑爱尔兰共和军，但他也说，
we want to keep loyal workers in employment in times of deep depression. So there's an economic context of this too. But this is not the only group that he's associated with. There's a whole series of a bewildering variety of factions and subgroups and whatnot. So I mentioned that he had a protégé called Noel Doherty. In April
“我们想在深度萧条时期让忠诚的工人保持就业。”所以这也有一个经济背景。但这并不是他与之相关的唯一团体。还有一系列令人眼花缭乱的派系和小组等等。所以我提到他有一个门徒叫诺埃尔·多尔蒂。在1966年4月
1966 with the anniversary of the Easter rising coming Docherty set up another group a vigilante group called the Ulster Protestant volunteers
随着复活节起义周年纪念日的临近，多尔蒂成立了另一个团体，一个治安维持团体，叫“阿尔斯特新教志愿者”。
The stated name of this group is we think the IRA going to launch an uprising on the anniversary of the Easter rising and we're going to be ready for them we'll have cells all over Alster
这个团体的既定名称是，我们认为爱尔兰共和军将在复活节起义周年纪念日发动起义，我们将为他们做好准备，我们在整个阿尔斯特都有小组，
and they will rise up on command the name the Ulster Protestant volunteers obviously is to evoke Carson's volunteers from 1912 the motto is the same for God and Ulster.
他们将听从指挥起义。名称“阿尔斯特新教志愿者”显然是为了唤起1912年卡森的志愿者，座右铭是一样的，“为了上帝和阿尔斯特”。
And like Carson's volunteers, they really want to get a hold of guns. So Doherty recruits very heavily among the B specials, the kind of police reservists, because they have been issued with revolvers and submachine guns, and they're allowed to keep their weapons at home. So this is a very useful thing for a paramilitary group. And Docti said later, my aim was to have a private army just like Carson did
而且像卡森的志愿者一样，他们真的想弄到枪。所以多尔蒂在B特种部队中大量招募，那种警察预备役人员，因为他们被发了左轮手枪和冲锋枪，而且他们被允许把武器留在家里。所以这对准军事组织来说是一件非常有用的事情。多尔蒂后来曾说：“我的目标是拥有一支私人军队，就像卡森那样。”
with the signing of the covenant. So Paisley would have had his own, a private army and he would have been a second Lord Carson. Can I ask Dominic, would the Protestants in Ulster at this point be ahead of the Catholics in terms of army? Well, given how many guns that be specials have, I would say probably yes. And actually when the IRA re-enter the story, let's say 1970, they don't have that many guns. And getting guns, armolites as they end up getting, becomes a real priority for them. Because of course, they've made the cardinal error, which you should never do, giving enough guns to the Welsh.
随着盟约的签署。所以佩斯利本可以拥有他自己的私人军队，他本可以成为第二个卡森勋爵。我可以问多米尼克，此时阿尔斯特的新教徒在军队方面会领先于天主教徒吗？嗯，考虑到B特种部队有多少枪，我会说可能是的。事实上，当爱尔兰共和军在1970年重新进入故事时，他们并没有那么多枪。而弄到枪，他们最终得到的阿玛莱特步枪，对他们来说成为了一个真正的优先事项。因为当然，他们犯了一个根本性的错误，你不应该这样做，给威尔士人足够的枪。
Yes, of course. And the Welsh don't want to give them back. Have you ever tried to reclaim a gun from a Welshman? I can't say I have. It's impossible. It can't be done. Okay. Well, that is a mistake then. Yeah. So anyway, Noel Doherty, this guy, is going round in the spring of 1966 trying to get guns and jet ignite. And he comes into contact at this point with another loyalist vigilante group that also looks back to Carson's volunteers. and this is a group called the Ulster Volunteer Force, the UVF.
是的，当然。而威尔士人不想把它们还回来。你有没有试过从威尔士人那里收回枪？我不能说我有。这不可能。这做不到。好吧，那是一个错误。是的。所以无论如何，诺埃尔·多尔蒂，这个家伙，在1966年春天到处试图弄到枪和炸药。此时他接触到了另一个也回顾卡森志愿者的效忠派治安维持团体，这是一个叫“阿尔斯特志愿军”（UVF）的团体。
And it's been founded a few months earlier by a group of men who used to meet in the pubs in the working class Protestant Shankill area. And the chief among them, and a big figure in the story of the troubles, although he's not so well known in Britain as some of the other figures, it's a man called Gusty Spence, who was in his early 30s. Spence's father had been Carson's volunteers, Spencer's father had also served in the First World War, Spence himself had been in the British Army. He'd been in Cyprus. He came home to Belfast. He worked as a scaffolder of the Harland and Wolf shipyards.
它是在几个月前由一群过去在工人阶级新教徒尚基尔地区酒吧聚会的男人创立的。其中最主要的人，也是“动乱”故事中的一个大人物，尽管他在英国不像其他一些人物那样出名，是一个叫古斯蒂·斯彭斯的人，他当时30出头。斯彭斯的父亲曾是卡森的志愿者，斯彭斯的父亲也曾在第一次世界大战中服役，斯彭斯本人曾在英国军队服役。他在塞浦路斯待过。他回到贝尔法斯特。他在哈兰德和沃尔夫造船厂做脚手架工。
So he sort of ticks all of these different boxes. Spence is a very hard man. He's no stranger to a brawl in a pub or something. He's a very keen member of the Orange Order. People look up to him because he's been in the army. There's a bit of an element, I think, about him and his friends of the old soldiers who are hanging around in the pub, talking about the old days,
所以他基本上符合所有这些不同的条件。斯彭斯是一个非常强硬的人。他对酒吧里的斗殴之类的事情并不陌生。他是橙色兄弟会非常热心的成员。人们尊敬他，因为他当过兵。我认为他和他的朋友们有一种老兵的元素，他们在酒吧里闲逛，谈论过去的日子，
trying to find something to do. They want to cause, basically. So in a way, that's kind of true of Mountbatten. Yeah. You know, all these kind of posh guys in the 70s wanting to, a military takeover. General Swalter Walker, Davis Sterling,
试图找点事做。他们基本上想要一个事业。所以从某种意义上说，这对蒙巴顿来说也是真的。是的。你知道，70年代所有这些时髦的家伙都想进行军事接管。沃尔特·沃克将军，戴维·斯特林，
all of these people. Yeah. Yeah, they look back to the war or something and they say, well, that was brilliant. I wish we could have that back again. I said of all these grubby political compromises and Harold Wilson's nasty raincoats. All of this.
所有这些人。是的。是的。他们回顾战争或什么，他们说，“嗯，那太棒了。我希望我们能把它找回来。”我说所有这些肮脏的政治妥协和哈罗德·威尔逊那件讨厌的雨衣。所有这些。
So I think with Gusty Spence and a lot of people like this, and this goes, by the way, for people on the Republican side, for people in the IRA, there was a sense of a romantic history of sort of outlaw violence and adventure and whatnot. It's all about the songs and the fiddles and the stories and all of that kind of thing. And they are almost willing it back into being because at a time when, you know, jobs are scarce, life seems shabby. and disappointing, this would give you a sense of excitement. And of course, if you ally that to the fear of the others, then that becomes a very potent combination. The sense is that there is nothing inevitable about the troubles. People choose it.
所以我认为对于古斯蒂·斯彭斯和很多这样的人来说，顺便说一句，这适用于共和派的人，适用于爱尔兰共和军的人，有一种关于非法暴力和冒险之类的浪漫历史感。这都是关于歌曲、小提琴和故事以及所有这些东西。他们几乎是在用意志让它重现，因为在工作稀缺、生活看起来破旧和令人失望的时候，这会给你一种兴奋感。当然，如果你把它与对他人的恐惧结合起来，那么这就变成了一种非常强大的组合。感觉“动乱”并不是不可避免的。人们选择了它。
People choose it. As you say, they will it into existence. Yes, they absolutely do. And I think they, this search for a cause, and it's a cause that they're very familiar with is a really important part of the story. Spence said later, there was still a sense, like with the old Ulster volunteers that you were for the cause, you would fight and die for it. Yes, fight and die for the cause. And that's so widespread among the people who join the different
人们选择了它。正如你所说，他们用意志让它存在。是的，他们绝对做到了。而且我认为他们，这种对事业的追求，而且这是一个他们非常熟悉的事业，是故事中非常重要的一部分。斯彭斯后来曾说，仍然有一种感觉，就像老阿尔斯特志愿者一样，你是为了事业，你会为它战斗和死亡。是的，为事业战斗和死亡。这在加入不同准军事组织的成员中非常普遍，
paramilitary groups, whether loyalist or Republican. Fight and die and kill? Well, this is the thing. So do you remember when we did the series about the Irish War of Independence with Paul Rouse? He said all the ballads are about fighting and dying, but people don't write ballads about fighting and killing, but someone's got to do the killing. Yeah. And actually, this brings us very neatly to May 1966 and the first, arguably the first casualties of the troubles. At this point, Spence and his pals have already started petrol bombing, Catholic schools,
无论是效忠派还是共和派。战斗、死亡和杀戮？嗯，这就是重点。所以你还记得我们和保罗·劳斯一起做关于爱尔兰独立战争的系列节目时吗？他说所有的民谣都是关于战斗和死亡的，但人们不写关于战斗和杀戮的民谣，但总得有人去做杀戮的事。是的。事实上，这非常巧妙地把我们带到了1966年5月，可以说是“动乱”的第一批伤亡者。此时，斯彭斯和他的伙伴们已经开始用汽油弹袭击天主教学校、
Catholic shops and so on. In their minds, they are deterring IRA vandalism. This is their excuse. Of course, an external observer would say, this looks very much like a drunken, sectarian vandalism and bullying to me. On the 7th of May, they decide to target a Catholic-owned pub just off the Shankill Road. They say loads of Republicans hang out in this pub, which should blow this pub up. And they throw a petrol bomb through what they think is the landlord's window.
天主教商店等等。在他们的脑海中，他们是在威慑爱尔兰共和军的破坏行为。这是他们的借口。当然，一个外部观察者会说，这在我看来非常像醉酒的、宗派主义的破坏行为和欺凌。5月7日，他们决定瞄准尚基尔路附近一家天主教拥有的酒吧。他们说很多共和派分子经常光顾这家酒吧，我们应该炸掉这家酒吧。他们向他们认为是房东窗户的地方扔了一枚汽油弹。
But actually, it's the house next door. And it belongs to a Protestant grandmother called Matilda Gould, who was 77 years old. She was bedridden with severe arthritis. She can't get out of bed. She's horribly burned by this petrol bomb. and she dies seven weeks later of her injuries. And a lot of accounts point to her as the first victim, first modern victim of the troubles.
但实际上，那是隔壁的房子。它属于一位叫玛蒂尔达·古尔德的77岁新教徒祖母。她因严重的关节炎卧床不起。她无法下床。她被这枚汽油弹严重烧伤，七周后因伤势过重去世。许多报道指出她是“动乱”的第一个受害者，第一个现代受害者。
And obviously this was a terrible mistake by the UVF to kill a Protestant grandmother. But in a sign of what's to come on both sides, they don't back down. They issue a statement two weeks later. From this day, we declare war against the IRA in its splinter groups. Known IRA men will be executed mercilessly and without hesitation, we solemnly warn the authorities to make no more speeches of appeasement.
显然，这是UVF杀死一位新教祖母的一个可怕错误。但作为双方未来将会发生什么的标志，他们没有退缩。两周后，他们发表了一份声明：“从今天起，我们向爱尔兰共和军及其分裂团体宣战。已知的爱尔兰共和军成员将被无情地处决，毫不犹豫。我们郑重警告当局不要再发表任何绥靖演讲。”
So there's two issues there. One is the sort of omnipresent, gnawing fear of the IRA that is there in loyalists' minds the whole time. But the IRA are a shadow at this point. They're very quiet at this point. I mean, a loyalist would say, come on, the IRA is still there, aren't they? And yes, they are still there, but or even though they're not actively campaigning. But the other thing is the attack on the authorities for appeasment. You know, this rhetoric runs right through the 60s and 70s.
所以那里有两个问题。一个是效忠派心中一直存在的对爱尔兰共和军那种无处不在的、啃噬般的恐惧。但此时爱尔兰共和军是一个影子。他们此时非常安静。我的意思是，一个效忠派会说，“得了吧，爱尔兰共和军还在那里，不是吗？”是的，他们确实还在那里，或者即使他们没有积极开展活动。但另一件事是对当局绥靖政策的攻击。你知道，这种修辞贯穿了整个60年代和70年代。
And on the 27th May, the UVF meet to discuss their next attack. They meet in a pub again. They said there's a bloke nearby called Leo Martin. He's a Republican activist. He's involved with the IRA. Let's go off and shoot him. And they go off to the Falls Road to go and find him and they can't find him. And on the way back, having not found him, they see walking down the street towards them,
5月27日，UVF开会讨论他们的下一次袭击。他们又在一家酒吧见面。他们说附近有一个叫里奥·马丁的家伙。他是一个共和派活动家。他参与了爱尔兰共和军。让我们去把他枪杀了吧。他们前往福尔斯路去寻找他，但找不到他。在回来的路上，因为没找到他，他们看到一个人正朝他们走来，
a bloke who's been in the pub all evening who's singing Republican songs he's called John Patrick Scullion he's 28 years old and they say well this bloke will do and they stab him and they shoot him and two weeks later he dies in hospital of his wounds and he's the second victim
一个整晚都在酒吧里唱歌的家伙，他唱着共和派的歌曲，他叫约翰·帕特里克·斯卡利恩，他28岁。他们说：“好吧，这个家伙就行。”他们刺伤了他，并枪杀了他。两周后，他在医院因伤势过重去世，他是第二个受害者。
and then a month later a third victim the evening of Saturday the 25th of June there are four young Catholics four young blokes they've been working in Belfar City Centre working late, they decide to go for a last pint at the Moulven Arms just off the Shankill Road because they know it stays open after hours. This pub, the Moulven Arms, is a Protestant pub, but one of these bloke says, it's fine, I know the landlord, this guy's called Andrew Kelly, he says, okay, I know the landlord, hell of no problem with us going there. They get to the
然后一个月后，第三个受害者。6月25日星期六晚上，有四个年轻的天主教徒，四个年轻的小伙子，他们在贝尔法斯特市中心工作，工作到很晚，他们决定去尚基尔路附近的莫尔文酒吧喝最后一杯啤酒，因为他们知道它在下班后仍然营业。这家酒吧，莫尔文酒吧，是一家新教酒吧，但其中一个家伙说：“没关系，我认识房东，这个家伙叫安德鲁·凯利，他说，好吧，我认识房东，我们去那里没问题。”他们在大约午夜到达
pub at about midnight, the pub is very busy, the landlord does know him, it's fine, they have no problem getting served, great. They sit down with their pints. Unknown to them, but sheer bad luck. The drinkers at the next table are gusty Spence and his gang. And one of the gangs said to the police later, the conversation came up about the religion of these fellows. Spence asked the company if they would be Catholics. Spence then went up to the bar beside the four lads to buy a drink.
酒吧，酒吧非常忙，房东确实认识他，没关系，他们被服务没问题，太棒了。他们坐下来喝啤酒。他们不知道，但纯粹是运气不好。隔壁桌的饮酒者是古斯蒂·斯彭斯和他的团伙。其中一个团伙后来告诉警察：“关于这些家伙的宗教信仰的谈话出现了。斯彭斯问同伴他们是否是天主教徒。斯彭斯然后走到四个小伙子旁边的吧台去买酒。”
When he returned to our table, he said, I've been listening to their conversation, they're four IRA men. They're IRA men. They will have to go. Which they're not. They're not IRA men. They're absolutely not. The four Catholic, young Catholic guys have their pints.
“当他回到我们的桌子时，他说：‘我一直在听他们的谈话，他们是四个爱尔兰共和军成员。他们是爱尔兰共和军成员。他们必须走。’”而他们不是。他们不是爱尔兰共和军成员。他们绝对不是。这四个年轻的天主教小伙子喝着他们的啤酒。
A couple of hours later, they leave the pub. And leading the way is one of them, Peter Ward, who is 18 years old. And as soon as they get outside, the shooting starts. Andrew Kelly again. He was dead, Peter Ward, when he hit the ground. I was shot too and I dropped down, but they kept on shooting at me. There were four gunmen. They didn't say anything.
几个小时后，他们离开了酒吧。带头的是其中一个，彼得·沃德，他18岁。当他们一到外面，枪声就开始了。安德鲁·凯利又说：“彼得·沃德中弹倒地时已经死了。我也中弹了，我倒下了，但他们继续向我射击。有四个枪手。他们什么也没说。”
All I remember is the flashes and the shooting. So one of them, this guy Peter Ward has killed. Spence and his gang were arrested and Spence and two others were sent to prison. Now, Paisley always condemns shootings of this kind. He's very happy to ratchet up the tension
“我只记得闪光和枪声。”所以其中一个，这个叫彼得·沃德的家伙被杀了。斯彭斯和他的团伙被捕，斯彭斯和其他两人被送进监狱。现在，佩斯利总是谴责这种枪击事件。他非常乐意在修辞上加剧紧张局势，
rhetorically, but he almost always distances himself from actual violence. And that again is something you, you know, he's not unusual in that regard. There are loads of people in their story who are very happy to kind of stoke the flames, but when the bullets fly, They always say, oh, no, I don't agree with this, of course.
但他几乎总是与实际的暴力保持距离。这又是你，你知道，他在那方面并不罕见。故事里有很多人非常乐意煽风点火，但当子弹飞来时，他们总是说：“哦，不，我当然不同意这一点。”
Do you think that's a cynical take, or is he acting on genuine principle when he condemns it? That is, I think, something that only he would know. That only he would know, if you're asking me my personal verdict, which not all thisers would agree with, I would say, I think there's an awful amount of cynicism from people in this story. So I'm not just talking about Ian Paisley, I'm talking about Jerry Adams or whoever. there are an awful lot of people who say, I don't really support violence, I don't really encourage it,
你认为这是一种愤世嫉俗的看法，还是他在谴责它时是出于真正的原则？我想那只有他自己知道。那只有他自己知道，如果你问我个人的裁决，并不是所有的历史学家都会同意，我会说，我认为这个故事里的人有大量的愤世嫉俗。所以我不仅仅是在谈论伊恩·佩斯利，我是在谈论杰里·亚当斯或任何人。有很多人说：“我并不真正支持暴力，我并不真正鼓励它，”
but everything that they do seems designed to encourage it because they believe it's in their political interests, frankly. Okay, okay. So, yeah, I would take a very caustic view of such people personally. And actually, to go back, just to finish on, Spence & Co,
但他们所做的一切似乎都是为了鼓励它，因为他们坦率地认为这符合他们的政治利益。好吧，好吧。所以，是的，我个人会对这样的人持非常尖刻的看法。事实上，回到，只是为了结束，斯彭斯和公司，
these killings were just so terrible to us. To some people, they give them a kind of outlaw appeal. They seem exciting. One writer later called Spencer Loyalist Folk Hero and there are lots of loyalist gunmen who joined paramountry who said yes
这些杀戮对我们来说太可怕了。对一些人来说，它们给了他们一种非法吸引力。它们看起来很令人兴奋。一位作家后来称斯彭斯为“效忠派民间英雄”，有很多加入准军事组织的效忠派枪手说：“是的，
he was my inspiration I really looked up to this guy he was the one person who had the guts to take up the gun and to actually do something positive to defend our people so I think that that's an important thing to bear in mind in Britain what do people think of all this do you know what most people don't even notice this is the summer of swinging London It's the summer of England's World Cup win.
他是我的灵感来源，我真的很尊敬这个家伙，他是唯一一个有胆量拿起枪并真正做点积极的事情来保卫我们人民的人。”所以我认为这是需要记住的重要一点。在英国，人们怎么看这一切？你知道，大多数人甚至没有注意到。这是摇摆伦敦的夏天。这是英格兰赢得世界杯的夏天。
Most people are completely uninterested in Northern Ireland. It doesn't really fit the mood these stories. Who cares that some people in a faraway place have been shooting each other if all your thoughts
大多数人对北爱尔兰完全不感兴趣。这些故事不太符合情绪。如果你的所有想法都是关于卡纳比街和迷你裙之类的东西，谁会在乎遥远地方的一些人在互相射击呢？但当然在贝尔法斯特，人们根本不是那样想的。特伦斯·奥尼尔曾去法国访问索姆河战役周年纪念，他缩短了行程
are of Carnaby Street and mini skirts and stuff. But of course in Belfast, people don't think that way at all. Terence O'Neill had been on a visit to France for the anniversary of the Somme and he cuts it short
回到斯托蒙特去谴责阿尔斯特志愿军。他说：“把自己比作卡森和他的志愿者是令人憎恶的。那些准备为国家在法国战场上牺牲的人与这种肮脏的罪犯阴谋之间没有任何联系。”他以这个非常戏剧性的警告结束，奥尼尔。他说，
to come back to Stormont and to denounce the Ulster Volunteer Force. He says, it's abominable to compare yourselves to Carson and his volunteers. There's no connection between men who are ready to die for the country and the fields of France and this sordid conspiracy of criminals. And he ends with this really dramatic warning, O'Neill. He says,
“北爱尔兰必须选择要么走进步之路，要么回到过去毫无意义的暴力中。”当他发表这篇演讲时，伦敦媒体说：“哦，这太棒了。奥尼尔发出了挑战。”人们无疑会团结在他周围，因为人们不想回到过去那种宗派仇恨中。但贝尔法斯特最大的报纸，
Northern Ireland must choose either the road to progress or return to the pointless violence of the past. When he gives the speech, the London press say, Oh, this is great. O'Neill is laying down the gauntlet. and people will undoubtedly rally to him because people don't want to go back to the sectarian hatreds of the past. But the biggest newspaper in Belfast,
《贝尔法斯特电讯报》，对当地情绪有更好的了解，却不那么乐观。它说：“由于那些一直在播种龙牙且不在乎收获会有多可怕的人，阿尔斯特正处于被抛回黑暗过去的危险之中。”但汤姆，那次收获将会比任何人意识到的要可怕得多。
the Belfast Telegraph, which has a much better sense of the local mood, is much less optimistic. It says Ulster is in danger of being thrown back into a dark past thanks to those who have been sewing dragons teeth and do not care how terrible the harvest may be. But Tom, that harvest will be much more terrible
所以下次我们将看看1968年的民权游行，德里的街头战斗，你的英雄吉姆·卡拉汉在经过大量推诿后决定派兵，以及爱尔兰共和军准备从阴影中重新出现。所以俱乐部成员可以听到那一集和整个系列。如果你不是会员，你当然可以在therestisistory.com获得会员资格。正如我们之前可能提到的，会员资格确实带有令人难以置信的补充福利，包括我们精彩的时事通讯，
than anybody realises. So next time we'll be looking at the civil rights marches of 1968, the fighting in the streets of Derry, your hero, Jim Callahan, deciding to send in the troops after a lot of prevarication and the IRA preparing to reemerge from the shadows. So club members can hear that episode and the entire series. And if you're not a member, you can, of course, get members. at the rest is history.com. And as we may have mentioned before, membership does come with an incredible rate of supplementary benefit, including our fantastic newsletter,
其中包括客座历史学家的文章、书籍摘录、测验、奖品，简直是无尽的乐趣。所以所有这些以及更多内容每周五都会发送到您的收件箱。所以多米尼克，成为会员的另一个绝佳理由。太多的理由了。太多的理由了。无论如何，谢谢大家的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克。再见，再见，再见。嘿，伙计们，我是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，为了《历史的其余部分》。美国。凯蒂·凯和我想要告诉你关于
which includes guest historian essays, book extracts, quizzes, prizes, just non-stop fun. So all of that and more in your inbox every Friday. So Dominic, another excellent reason to become a member. So many reasons. So many reasons. Anyway, thank you everyone for listening. Thank you, Dominic. And bye bye bye. Hey, guys, Anthony Scaramucci for the rest is politics. US. Caddy Kay and I want to tell you about
我们十月份的北美巡演。唐纳德·特朗普正在改写美国的历史。从贸易战到移民打击，再到全球冲突，我们在这里理清这一切。你知道，我们处于一个由去极化定义的时代。而美国的制度在唐纳德·特朗普的领导下正在崩溃。凯蒂和我将现场直播，剖析真正发生的事情，分享内部视角，并回答你们的问题。今年十月，我们将前往多伦多、波士顿、纽约、
our North American tour in October. Donald Trump is rewriting the history of the United States. From trade wars to immigration crackdowns to global conflicts, we are here to make sense of all of it. You know, we're in an era defined by depolarization. and American institutions are breaking under Donald Trump. Katty and I will be live on stage, breaking down what's really happening, sharing insider perspectives, and answering your questions. This October, we're heading to Toronto, Boston, New York,
华盛顿特区，以及其他许多美国城市，深入参与所有的政治行动。我们很乐意在那里见到你们。快来加入我们吧。所以前往therestispoliticsus.com获取你的门票，并来看我们的现场直播。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Washington, D.C., a host of other American cities, to get into all of the political action. We would love to see you there. Come and join us. So head to the rest is politics, US.com, to get your tickets and come see us live. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
华盛顿特区以及其他许多美国城市，去参与所有的政治活动。我们非常希望能见到你们。快来加入我们吧。所以请前往therestispoliticsus.com获取门票，来现场看我们。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。